Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pritlov und äh es ist Freitag der achtzehnte Dezember zwanzig zwanzig.
Worüber soll's, sonst sollten wir reden als über Korona hier ist das Corona Wickly mit mir und natürlich mit Pavel, hallo Paul.
Ja ist wieder einiges auf der Liste gelandet, worüber es sich dann doch zu sprechen lohnt, Deutschland äh ist nach wie vor in Aufruhr
und ja da können wir unser Tojuso Potential wieder voll ausnutzen, nehme ich mal an.
Aber darum geht's natürlich hier eigentlich nicht.
Ja wir wollen eigentlich nur schlechte Laune verbreiten heute.
Mit Erfolg. Das können wir. Ja.
Ansonsten hat sich an deinem äh deiner generellen Lebenssituation irgendwas geändert. Also ich habe mich ja jetzt schon auf äh äh Lokdown bis Ende März mental eingerichtet, damit ich nie von nichts enttäuscht werde. Ich glaube, das ist so die richtige Grundhaltung.
Ja, ja. Also ich habe obwohl
meine Kontakte schon äh äh sehr, sehr gering waren, also persönliche Kontakte habe ich jetzt wirklich nur noch irgendwie ein, zwei Leute, äh die ich so regelmäßig treffe und.
Ansonsten ja äh halte ich mich komplett fern, soweit es denn irgend nur.
Geht von Geschäften oder äh ja anderen Menschenansammlungen oder Feiern.
Besser ist das, geht mir ähnlich. Also es äh gerade dieses Weihnachten, das ist komplett abgesagt, ansonsten bin ich ganz gut beschäftigt mit Leuten zu telefonieren und ihnen zu erzählen, dass sie irgendwie.
Doch die Wahl zwischen diesem und allen anderen Weihnachten äh fällen sollten und äh ja,
stößt zunehmenden Maße auch auf Verständnis. Ich kann ja verstehen, dass es für manche Leute mental so ein bisschen schwierig ist, aber dieses sich jetzt an dieses Datum hängen und am Ende,
Seien wir ehrlich, Weihnachten ist nur ein Datum, ja.
Ums Treffen und ums Feiern und zusammen äh sein geht, kann ich das alles verstehen, aber das muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt an diesem Datum machen. Das kann man auch im März machen.
Oder so. Da kann man im Prinzip.
Genau sich Urlaub nehmen und genau das selbe Ding durchziehen und äh wenn uns der Klimawandel treu bleibt, dann haben wir auch im März noch Chancen, hochweise Weihnachten.
Ja heute gerade auch die tragische Geschichte von jemanden, der irgendwie
noch vor sechs Wochen oder so, dann versucht hat auf seinen Vater einzuwirken, der das alles nicht so ernst genommen hat und ja
leider den Vater dann vor zwei Tagen jetzt irgendwie verloren hat an Korona. So, mein Gott passiert. Ich mein.
Okay, man kann natürlich nach wie vor, wenn man, wenn man sicher gehen will, begibt man sich vorher in Selbstquarantäne, das machen halt auch viele und äh ja
Dann geht es vielleicht auch, wenn man dann aber nicht
sich halt jetzt mit zehn Leuten in Familie triff,
oder so, weil das Problem sind jetzt nicht die zehn Leute an sich, sondern wahrscheinlich in jeder Familie mit zehn Leuten äh wird es denn einen geben, der es nicht so ernst nimmt.
Das ist so, dass das Problem beziehungsweise je mehr Leute auf einen Haufen sind so
umso wahrscheinlicher, dass da jemand dabei ist, der einfach, ja nicht aufpasst.
Ja und es gibt noch so einen zweiten äh Faktor, der mir bei dem Gespräch auch klar wurde, so nicht, also dann ne, Weihnachten mit ist ja dieses.
Extrem aufgeladene Fest. So, dieses alles soll schön sein und und man will irgendwie auch so eine, so eine so eine, so eine Normalität äh äh feiern und dann soll's halt toll sein und es muss gegessen werden und es muss dann auch,
für jede Person, die da ist, soll's angenehm sein, so, ne? Und dann erzählte mir auch mein Freund auch so, ja, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie meine Mutter irgendwie äh besuche,
Dann redet sie also oder wenn ich jetzt mit ihr telefoniere, dann redet sie die ganze Zeit davon, was ja, was denn der Sohn noch haben will, so und äh sah sie dann halt im geistigen.
'ne Vorstellung halt auch schon so ja nochmal im Supermarkt rennen und das nochmal besorgen und hier nochmal 'n Geschenk besorgen und weißt du einfach kümmern und sich einfach noch mehr nach draußen bewegen und das ist einfach alles nicht gut.
Also ich will niemanden äh seinen Weihnachtserlebnis wegnehmen im eigentlichen Sinne, aber.
Bin einfach der Auffassung, man muss es nicht unbedingt an diesem Datum machen, denn es geht nicht ums Datum. Es geht nur dadrum, dass man irgendwann im Jahr diesen Zeitpunkt findet, da kann man das dann machen,
aber der verschiebt sich halt dieses Jahr einfach ein bisschen. Und mehr ist halt auch nicht dabei. Schauen wir mal auf
Die Zahlen, wie sie sich in Deutschland so entwickelt haben, nachdem wir ja längere Zeit diese Stagination hatten und alles so ein bisschen verzweifelt daran sind, dass es halt nicht besser wird, wird's,
Jetzt langsam wieder schlechter, wie schlecht wird's denn?
Ja, also seit.
Zwei Tagen gehen die Zahlen wieder hoch, nicht ganz so schnell wie vorher, aber so optisch, wenn man sich das anguckt,
Ja, ist die Steigung jetzt auch nicht viel geringer als jetzt beim ersten Anlauf, den die zweite Welle genommen hat oder wie auch immer man das nennen will. Jedenfalls seit zwei Wochen gehen wieder
alle Zahlen nach oben ungefähr vierundzwanzigtausend Neuinfektionen pro Tag.
Sieben Tage Schnitt, also das ist schon ja ich mein wir hatten glaube ich in der ersten.
Welle sind wir so auf insgesamt fast hundertzwanzigtausend gekommen oder so, das heißt, wir haben jetzt in einer Woche im Moment so viele Neuinfektionen wie in der ganzen ersten Welle.
So und äh die ist jetzt halt schon,
viermal so hoch, äh wie die erste Welle und es sieht noch nicht aus, dass da irgendwas abflachen würde
Und jetzt kann man sagen, okay, bei der ersten Welle war das halt untererfasst, da wurde noch nicht so viel getestet, aber wenn man jetzt rein nur die Zahl der Toten äh vergleicht, bisher, dann äh sind
wir äh jetzt schon doppelt so hoch wie auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle, ja? Und.
Es zieht eher weiter an und wir können relativ sicher sein, dass es auch die nächsten zwei Wochen äh noch nach oben gehen.
Wird mit den Zahlen und dass wir halt bald leider so die äh mehr als tausend Toten,
pro Tag erreichen und überschreiten werden. Das ist eigentlich kaum zu vermeiden. Die Leute haben sich bereits schon angesteckt, die dann sterben.
Werden.
Wenn ich das mal so deute, also wir haben jetzt mindestens eine Welle, die dreimal, wenn ich vier Mal oder sogar noch häufiger so stark ist wie die erste Welle.
Also von der rein von der von der Höhe her.
Genau, also in der Summe sozusagen äh wird das Ausmaß noch sehr viel größer sein, so.
Das ist,
bitter und äh was aber auch interessant ist, wenn man so guckt ist, dass die Kurve der Toten gar nicht so richtig der Kurve
der Neuinfektion, die erfasst wurden folgt bei der Neuinfektion hatten wir ja so ein Plateau,
Vor sechs Wochen, was dann so vier, fünf Wochen anhielt und eigentlich müsste man ja jetzt erwarten, dass dann die Zahl der Toten so mit zwei, drei Wochen Abstand hinterher,
einen ähnlichen Knick macht, tut sie aber nicht.
Eine Erklärung dafür.
Ja, der Hauptgrund dafür äh dürfte darin liegen, dass sich zwar,
insgesamt in allen Altersgruppen hat es diesen Knick oder dieses Plateau gegeben, aber äh nicht,
bei den über Achtzigjährigen, ja. Da hat sich die Institz einfach anders entwickelt
und es ist also eine demografisches äh Ding hauptsächlich plus noch ein bisschen Testregime, spielt da wahrscheinlich auch noch äh rein an der Stelle. Äh dass der Knick nicht ganz so
ausgeprägt war äh in Wirklichkeit wie er sich in den Zahlen äh darstellt
Aber das sind so die die sagen die beiden Ursachen dafür, dass leider die Zahl der Toten bisher noch nicht
flacht und wir auch nicht absehen können so richtig wann das passieren wird.
Ja. Was ist denn der der Erbe bei den bei den Toten? Der geht ja auch beständig nach oben, ne?
Nö, nicht ganz der bewegt sich so zwischen eins Komma zwei und eins Komma fünf.
Tja, das ist eine ganze Menge Holz bei schon ohnehin so hohen Todeszahlen. Also das äh bedeutet, dass das eben mit bis zu fünfzig Prozent Schwung nach oben geht, so. Exponentiell. Das ist äh eine Menge.
Sehr unschön.
Und es ist halt auch in der Fläche so, wenn man im Moment hinschaut, äh steigen.
Ähm die Zahlen in allen Bundesländern. So und es gibt auch seit.
Längerem kein Bundesland mehr unter fünfzig, selbst hier Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Schleswig-Holstein, die noch relativ weit unten liegen, äh nähern sich jetzt den hundert.
Beziehungsweise Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat die hundert bereits überschritten und Schleswig-Holstein liegt bei vierundneunzig pro hunderttausend Einwohner äh Fällen.
In den letzten sieben Tagen.
Also es gibt anderen Worten keine wirklich sicheren Bundesländer mehr und am schlimmsten ist halt in Sachsen mit vierhundertvierundvierzig.
Und ansonsten seit Thüringen, Baden-Württemberg, Saarland und Brandenburg, die jetzt über dem Bundesdurchschnitt liegen.
Alle anderen liegen bisschen besser da. Was aber auch wirklich bemerkenswert ist.
Ist, dass wir jetzt in den top dreißig neunzehn Ostdeutsche Landkreise haben, dass ja kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass das an irgendeinem Freitag.
Mal so war in den letzten Wochen die Top fünf sind alles ostdeutsche Landkreise und.
Alle Hotspots in den Top dreißig liegen auf dem Land oder in der Provinz. Es gibt keine Großstadt in den Top dreißig, ja. Das heißt.
Brennt im Moment vor allem auf dem Land. Kann man sagen.
Und vor allem in den Ländern, die von der ersten Welle noch weniger betroffen waren.
Das spielt vielleicht auch eine Rolle, so bisschen der Sang der Tschechieneffekt
wo man die erste Welle so gut gemeistert hat, dass man glaubt, man hat das halt alles im Griff und es ist sicherlich auch ein Problem in Deutschland, weil sich bei uns halt auch scheinbar,
Überzeugung festgesetzt hat bei vielen, na ja, irgendwie haben wir das schon im Griff. Das war die erste Welle war ja halb so wild.
So, das haben wir ja ganz schnell unter Kontrolle gekriegt und dann war ja alles gut.
Ja, die Hotspots sind in Bayern und sind in im Saarland und sind in Nordrhein-Westfalen und in Baden-Württemberg und das ist ja alles ganz weit weg und das stimmte auch. Das war damals alles ganz weit weg. Nur in den letzten Monaten
hat sich eben alles schön großflächig verteilt. Das heißt überall war sozusagen die Saat gelegt und in dem Moment, wo man dann halt nachlässiger vorgeht
breitete sich weiter aus und dann über das schon so oft gehabt haben, ist man immer sehr überrascht, wenn's halt auf einmal exponentiell zuschlägt. Ich denke, Sachsen dürfte jetzt insbesondere noch davon betroffen sein, einerseits durch die Nähe nach Polen,
die Zahlen ja nochmal massiver sind und in Tschechien auch,
Ja, also das so das ist sozusagen auch am Rand Bayerns zu Tschechien war's ja auch schon immer so ein bisschen kritisch, ob das jetzt wirklich was mit Grenzverkehr zu tun hat
will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, aber es ist äh einfach offensichtlich, dass wir jetzt äh im Erzgebirge und so weiter, also alles, was grenznah ist, ist besonders betroffen.
Und es zieht halt jetzt durch Sachsen, nach äh Sachsen-Anhalt, in den Süden, in den Süden Brandenburgs rein, also es gibt noch einen großen Unterschied zwischen Norden und Süden von Brandenburg,
Zahlen gehen aber überall insgesamt hoch, sodass einfach überhaupt nicht davon auszugehen ist, dass jemand mittelfristig nicht betroffen ist. Am besten steht halt derzeit Schleswig-Holstein da.
Aber wie gesagt, so ein Ab
Down Downward Trends scheint es ja nirgendswo so richtig zu geben. Von daher ist es alles nur eine Frage der Zeit und es ist halt auch alles so wunderbar äh relativ. Also ich meine, Schleswig-Holstein hat jetzt eine eine Inszedenz von vierundneunzig.
Und was erinnern wir uns noch schön, als es äh Anfang äh November, Ende Oktober, wie sich alle auf einmal so unglaublich über Berlin aufgeregt haben, ha, Berlin hier irgendwie,
Über fünfzig Höllen, Höllenpool. Ja, Berliner dürften nicht mehr in die Schweiz und so.
Ist immer so leicht sich da ähm gut zu fühlen, aber wir sehen halt jetzt an den Zahlen und was du gesagt hast, hier Sachsen über vierhundert,
wenn man dann auf Landkreisebene runtergeht, gibt's ja.
Extreme Ausreißer mittlerweile, also so die die Topenzidenz, äh was es jetzt gerade am schlimmsten.
Also ich äh habe jetzt verschiedene Sachen äh gehört im Erzgebirge, das ist jetzt teilweise auch schon in den Tausender und Zweitausender Bereich geht.
Ein ein Landkreis mit zweitausendneunhundert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in deinen Zahlen jetzt schon wieder.
Nenne nicht Land, das sind nicht Landkreise, sondern auf Gemeindeebene.
Ja okay, Gemeinden.
Die wird hier nicht aus aufgelöst, aber einzelne Gemeinden sollen wohl,
irgendwie deutlich über tausend mittlerweile liegen, aber die Zahlen äh äh werden halt so nicht veröffentlicht oder erhoben. Das machen dann die Ämter vor Ort nochmal, die brechen das dann runter.
Aber ja.
Im Moment sind so sind's so siebenhundertvierzig auf Landkreisebene die höchste Institu Oberspreewald Lausitz und Regen.
In äh Bayern und Ersteres natürlich in Brandenburg.
Ja und Sachsens auch mit einem siebenhundertvierunddreißiger Landkreis dabei, also ja.
Man muss sich das nochmal klar machen und ich äh äh.
Geht nochmal ganz kurz in den Konzentrationsphase rein, um mich nicht wieder in der Zehnerpotenz zu vertun, ne. Aber wenn ihr so in eine Gemeinde, wie ich das gerade gelesen habe, ich kann den Namen grad nicht sagen.
Eine Gemeinde so eine Institz hat von zweitausendneunhundert. Sagen wir mal drei dreitausend.
Von hunderttausend in der Woche, das bedeutet drei Prozent der Bevölkerung in dieser Gemeinde steckt sich an jede Woche.
Mhm.
So, jede Woche drei Prozent. Plus Dunkelziffer. Also da ist dann, da höre ich dir auch wirklich schon die die Herden äh Immunität trapsen.
Leider nicht, die stellt sich halt erst so bei R vierzig Prozent oder so macht sich die dann bemerkbar oder.
Ja gut, aber wenn jede Woche drei Prozent dazukommt, dann bist du da halt auch bald. So, das ist das, was ich damit sagen möchte.
Na ja, meistens passiert's natürlich nicht äh weil äh ja, aber in der Tat drei Prozent in in einer Woche.
Sind dann immer noch zehn Wochen, um auf dreißig Prozent zu kommen und ja, solange wird das hoffentlich nicht bleiben. Aber interessant ist auch noch, wenn ich sagen wollte.
Es scheint auch so zu sein, dass Wellen sagen regional.
Zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten ankommen,
Das heißt, was man oft sieht, ist, dass in den Ländern, wo es Ausbrüche gab und wo es als erstes hoch äh ging, es auch dann als erstes wieder zurückgeht und das in Ländern.
Oder gegen einen, die länger eigentlich ganz gut aussahen, während dann die grünen Länder dann schon wieder auf dem Weg nach unten sind, geht es halt in den späten Ländern nach oben und das ist in dem Fall jetzt
auch ja zum einen der Osten, aber gerade eben auch Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und,
Schleswig-Holstein, so die besten Chancen hat eigentlich im Moment Bremen äh nach unten zu kommen gerade, weil diese haben auch eine relativ niedrige Institz und steigen halt zumindest nicht während,
so
Pomm und äh Schleswig-Holstein so zwanzig, dreißig Prozent jede Woche mehr an Fällen dazu kriegen. Also also die neue Neuerkrankung, die ins Ideenski zwanzig dreißig Prozent pro Woche hoch,
da ist man dann natürlich auch in drei Wochen dann ähm kann man da auch drei, vier Wochen äh auf,
einen Rekordplatz kommen. Werden wir sehen.
Ja, aber auch Bremen hat mein Air von eins, also es ist.
Aber ich find's, wie gesagt, auch.
Mal jetzt interessant äh diese diese Stadtlandkluft im Moment, dass sich das Ganze vor allem auf dem Land,
abspielt. Selbst im Westen, also vor allem im Osten aufm Land, aber selbst die, sage mal, ein Drittel Westdeutscher Landkreise in den in den top,
dreißig sind auch alles so ja Provinzstädte, keine Großstadt dabei, ja? Und
Ich frage mich ja, ob das ja tatsächlich einfach an der Einstellung der Leute liegt, dass man sagt, okay, man kennt sich und vertraut sich und passt halt deswegen äh nicht auf, so
möchte jetzt niemanden verdächtigen äh infiziert zu sein, weil einem das peinlich ist.
Und verzichtet dann deswegen auf Schutzmaßnahmen. Ich weiß es nicht. Scheint mir fast das Plausibelste zu sein.
Schwierig zu erklären, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so. Aber ich bin jetzt mal eben durch deine ganze Tabelle durchgescrollt, während wir also hier im Sommer noch so die Situation hatten, dass nahezu fast alles grün war.
Ist jetzt einfach alles rot.
Rot oder superrot, eins von beiden, aber eigentlich ist fast fast alles super rot. Na ja gut und so ist halt die Situation.
Und man kann,
auch sagen jetzt bei den bei den Zahlen ist ja immer wieder das Thema ähm wie verlässlich sind die und,
hilft dann immer ein Blick auf die Testzahlen und nachdem die Testzahlen so vier Wochen lang in Folge ähm gesunken sind.
So sind sie jetzt das erste Mal äh wieder gestiegen. Also es gab,
zehn Komma sieben Prozent mehr Tests und es gab aber zwanzig Komma sieben Prozent mehr positive Tests, das heißt die positiven Rate ist jetzt auch auf einem neuen Höchstwert gestiegen,
elfeinhalb Prozent.
Und äh ja anderen Worten äh die Zahlen über die wir gerade geredet haben sind ziemlich real und kein Artifakt des Tests.
So auf Bundesebene.
Positiven Rate von zehn Prozent ist natürlich auch zu hoch. Die WHO-Empfehlung ist fünf Prozent sollten es sein.
Gibt natürlich auch noch Länder, die bei denen sieht's ganz anders aus USA teilweise hatten wir auch, glaube ich, schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass es so Regionen gibt mit was weiß ich, fünfzig, sechzig Prozent positiven Rate. Da ist natürlich alles total untertestet. Ähm,
An dem Punkt sind wir jetzt nicht, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall ganz sinnvoll, auch noch diese positiven Rate runterzubekommen, um einfach überhaupt das Gefühl zu bekommen, dass man die Situation als solche erfasst.
Definitiv. Also auch, ich, man kann sagen, je höher die positiven Rate, umso größer auch das Dunkelfeld.
So dass glaube ich ein Zusammenhang äh mal so sagen kann und äh ja, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt notwendigerweise proportional, aber,
Ähm,
dann sagen die Zahlen sind mindestens um die Werte gestiegen, die wir jetzt äh gesagt haben, tendenziell war das Infektionsgeschehen minimal höher.
Ja also so viel zum.
Bunt, also Deutschlandebene in Berlin sieht's ein bisschen anders aus. Sie hat ja schon gesagt.
In vielen Gegenden wo,
früher hochgeht, geht's dann auch früher runter, beziehungsweise in Berlin ist es äh in den ja bis vor drei Wochen.
Leicht so.
Schule stärker gesunken als im Bund und seit drei Wochen haben wir in Berlin zum Glück kein großen Anstieg bei den
Neuinfektionszahlen, sondern mehr oder weniger eine Seitwärtsbewegung, aber es ist unglaublich, wie,
die Tageswerte schwank.
Also das ist auch ich meine wir hatten so in den letzten vierzehn Tagen der niedrigste berichtete Tageswert Berlin waren.
Hundertfünfzig Neuinfektionen, ja und der höchste Wert waren.
Achthundertfünfzig Neuinfektionen am Tag, das heißt äh die Wander haben natürlich nicht an dem Tag stattgefunden, aber
es ist so, dass an manchen Tagen halt äh ja sechs mal so viele Fälle bearbeitet werden, wie an anderen Tagen oder berichtet werden, obwohl,
die natürlich nicht nicht wirklich so schwanken. Was nicht stagniert ist jetzt die Zahl der To.
So und das liegt da ganz klar an der Altersgruppe achtzig plus, weil in Berlin sind halt ähm.
Der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig, vor allem die Zahlen zurückgegangen,
und äh aber in achtzig plus sind sie hochgegangen in anderen Altersgruppen mehr oder weniger gleich geblieben, sodass halt,
jetzt zu erwarten ist, dass die Zahl der Toten in den nächsten Wochen in Berlin auch noch weiter steigt.
Selbst wenn die Zahl der Fälle ähm jetzt in den letzten drei Wochen konstant geblieben ist.
Und in Berlin sind die Labore auch wieder überlastet. Äh so da ich das wieder mehr Tests jetzt gemacht wurden, reicht die Berliner Laborkapazität nicht aus, um,
ja alle Tests in Berlin durchzuführen, sondern es wird halt wahrscheinlich wieder verschickt nach München oder so. Ja.
Was halt auch nicht so schön ist und weil's nochmal in die Bezirke reinguckt, stellt man halt fest, äh in der Hälfte der Bezirke.
Gehen die Zahlen hoch in der Hälfte der Bezirke, gehen die Zahlen runter
einzelne Bezirke hüpfen immer mal hoch an die Spitze, um dann wieder äh zu sinken, was im Wesentlichen daran liegt, dass es äh immer wieder spektakuläre Ausbrüche in Altersheim.
Dass es äh einfach der Hintergrund, dass plötzlich man feststellt, upsi äh zwei Drittel,
unserer ja Leute in dem Heim und die Hälfte der Belegschaft sind plötzlich positiv.
Sowas passiert natürlich nicht von einem Tag auf den anderen, sondern sowas ist natürlich Folge von ja ähm.
Einerseits schlichten Management.
Andererseits natürlich von auch schwierigen Bedingungen, wenn die Hälfte von deinem Personal ausgefallen ist,
hatten wir öfter, dass das Thema, was was machst du eigentlich und dann ist es eben auch so, ist jetzt nicht gerade der bestbezahlte Job, gerade in der Altenpflege, vor allem im Verhältnis,
zu dem, was man da leisten muss und,
Ja es arbeiten halt auch deswegen sehr viele unqualifizierte Hilfskräfte dort aber.
Muss auch sagen, man kann jetzt nicht auch einfach den Heim äh und den Leuten, die da arbeiten, allein die Schuld zuschieben, äh sondern muss auch sagen, die sind ganz offensichtlich mit ihrer Überforderung dann allein gelassen worden, auch,
und.
Hätten vielleicht von sich aus irgendwann halt um Hilfe schreiben, was ich denke, es gibt Methoden und Möglichkeiten, wenn man so ein Heim leitet, sich dann einfach an die Gesundheitsbehörden zu wenden und zu sagen, hier.
Wir können die Patienten nicht mehr versorgen oder wir können hier die Alten nicht mehr versorgen, weil wir einfach kein Personal mehr haben, weil unser Personal erkranktes stat.
Dann Personal einzusetzen, äh was dann möglicherweise noch Symptome äh auflässt.
Lös die Frage, was das Gesundheitsamt dann tun soll. Also ich meine, Personal haben die auch nicht.
Es gibt schon Möglichkeiten äh dort. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass äh ja äh.
Was was jetzt passiert oder was halt nicht geht, ist, dass halt dann so ein Leiter da komplett alleine gelassen wird und äh dann versucht das irgendwie zurechtzumorscheln.
Am Ende sind dann zwei Drittel der Patienten krank und müssen dann in Krankenhäuser verlegt werden und zehn Prozent sterben und so. Ja, das ist ja auch nicht, das ist Kaya nicht der Weg sein.
Ja, dann lieber vorher die weiße Fahne hissen und sagen hier äh so und ich gehe mal ach sogar davon aus, dass sie eigentlich dazu verpflichtet wären, sowas zu tun, wenn sie nicht mehr klarkommen.
Aber klar, das ist dann die Angst davor, den Job zu verlieren oder aber am Ende des Tages wird's ja nicht besser, wenn einem die Leute wegsterben.
Lass mal halt auch so ein bisschen unser Umfeld äh das Umfeld von Deutschland schauen.
Ähm da ist interessant, wenn man jetzt mal so guckt, wie ist es denn jetzt in den Nachbarländern gelaufen. So, dann stellt man fest,
viele Länder haben ja eine ziemlich heftige Welle durchgemacht so Holland, Tschechien, Belgien.
Und bei aber ja gerade in Holland, Tschechien und in der Schweiz.
Ziehen die Fallzahlen jetzt wieder an, nachdem sie durch relativ harte Lockdowns erstmal recht stark gesenkt wurden.
So und Dänemark war sehr lange ja vergleichbar mit uns, Diagnase auch.
Fast die gleichen Institzen wie uns, haben dann auch einen Plateau erreicht, aber irgendwie geht's da jetzt äh äh richtig ab.
Auf einmal also nur hoffen, dass das jetzt nicht das ist, was uns auch droht, aber
Ja ähm sieht ganz so aus, als wenn
genau der Fall sein könnte. Ähm,
sonst in Österreich, Italien und Polen haben auch deutlich gesenkt, aber äh da geht's zumindest nicht mehr weiter runter, da ist noch so ein bisschen,
Unentschieden. So und wenn man jetzt das Ganze mit Deutschland vergleicht, dann sieht man.
In Deutschland die Dynamik deutlich geringer ist, also sieht dann fast flach aus in Deutschland, der Graf, aber,
Trotzdem haben wir halt sehr robust steigende Zahlen in in Deutschland, die machen da nicht so richtig viel.
Bewegung. Und ansonsten ja Frankreich und Belgien,
sind halt sehr weit runtergekommen unter deutsche Instit
werte jetzt, aber auch da sind die Faltzahlen noch zu hoch und sinken auch nicht weiter. Also,
mit anderen Worten. Äh es gibt jetzt kein Beispiel um uns herum direkt.
Wo man sagen könnte, okay, die hat eine richtig große Welle und sind jetzt wieder so weit runtergekommen
dass sie jetzt wirklich wieder lockern könnten. Das es irgendwie sicher ist oder dass sie überhaupt nur mit Tracking und Tracing irgendwas erreichen äh konnten, sondern es scheint halt,
wie ganz ganz schwierig zu sein jetzt unter einem Institzwert,
von hundert zu kommen, ja? Äh das ist ja,
flacht dann halt äh aus irgendeinem Grund alles ab und wahrscheinlich ist es dann auch Maßnahmenmüdigkeit und natürlich hier und da auch einzelne Lockerungen.
Und ähm ja und wenn man sich jetzt noch die Todesfälle anguckt, dann.
Sieht man plötzlich nochmal ein ganz anderes Bild und da ist es so, dass jetzt gerade Österreich und die Schweiz ähm so sich,
zu
Todeshotspots entwickeln, kann man nicht anders sagen. Also gerade Österreich sieht so aus, als wenn es wenn das so weitergeht.
Belgien äh schlagen.
Könnte, also den Hochstand von Belgien. Im Moment sind sie schon nicht sechzig, siebzig Prozent höher als als Belgien und die Schweiz auch und in der Schweiz. Ich habe mich da mal ein bisschen mit der Situation.
Beschäftigt, warum gehen denn da die Zahlen jetzt hoch und gab's da eigentlich nur einen Lokdown, weil eigentlich gab's in der Schweiz,
nicht so richtig einen landesweiten Lokdown, aber es gab halt unglaublich viele Einzelmaßnahmen in einzelnen Kantonen, die halt teilweise sehr,
hart waren, aber es gab nie so den äh großen schweizweiten Loktown und.
Ja es äh sehr gespannt wie das da jetzt weitergeht im Land der Basisdemokratie.
Ja
Scheinen ähnliche Probleme zu haben, sich auf auf zentrale Maßnahmen zu einigen, wie man das äh in Deutschland auch sieht. Ja, also,
nicht sagen generell, dass,
dezentral organisierte Länder hier im Nachteil sind, ja? So ist ja Deutschland insgesamt, gerade wenn man jetzt mal die Nachbarländer oder andere europäische äh Länder sieht, äh noch relativ gut dabei.
Woran das dann liegt schwierig zu sagen, aber dieses Hickhack,
um den November-Lok dauern. Kann man, glaube ich, schon festhalten, dass das halt eigentlich primär gefüttert war,
vor in so einem jedes Bundesland sieht es anders und jedes Bundesland hat da noch irgendwie was nochmal so eine Sonderausnahme für sich rausgehandelt oder man kann sie halt insgesamt nicht zu einer koordinierten, zentralen Maßnahme.
Bringen und na ja, das äh war eigentlich nicht so klug, weil.
Ist immer dieselbe Geschichte. Am Ende müssen wir es dann doch machen. Und dann tut's noch mehr weh.
Ja grundsätzlich kann man natürlich sagen ist an der Idee ähm okay, wir haben halt.
Unterschiedliche Maßnahmen, wo die Situation
unterschiedlich gefährlich ist, kann man natürlich auch was abgewinnen, also vor allen Dingen auch in dem Land, äh wie äh Deutschland was interessieren mich in Berlin irgendwie, wenn ja,
achthundert Kilometer weiter irgendwo Infektion stattfinden muss dann sagen, so aber eigentlich.
Mal sagen spielt diese Differenzierung nur bei wirklich.
Ganz, ganz niedrigen Institzen eine Rolle. Also ich würde sagen, okay, wenn der Landkreis Kowitt frei ist so und es da seit zwei Wochen keine Übertragungen nachgewiesen worden sind, dann meinetwegen.
So, aber alle Bundesländer äh befinden sich im Moment in,
Bereichen, wo es gar keinen Sinn macht, wirklich zu differenzieren, weil selbst wenn jetzt eine selbst bei dem besten äh Bundesland,
jetzt mit äh äh Schleswig-Holstein, mit einer Institanz von neunzig. Selbst dieses Bundesland würde halt von einem maximal harten Lokdown sogar noch äh
profitieren, weil die werden dann halt ruckzuck
unten, bei denen wäre dann der Lokdown halt in äh ja drei Wochen wäre der Drops gelutscht und sie werden unter zwanzig oder könnten dann vielleicht sogar es ist ausrotten bei
wirklich harten Maßnahmen und bei denen die jetzt bei äh sechs äh siebenhundert oder ja vierhundert äh.
Land liegen, bei denen ist es erst recht geboten. Ähm das zu machen.
Ja, aber ein Ding vielleicht noch äh jetzt ähm
zum zum Ländervergleich, was interessant ist, ist das Holland und Dänemark, das irgendwie geschafft haben, wohl ihre alten recht gut zu schützen,
jedenfalls liegen, dass die Zahlen äh nahe, weil äh obwohl in Dänemark,
die Infektion nach oben gegangen sind, sind die Zahlen der,
toten längst nicht so angestiegen wie in Deutschland und wir haben jetzt in Deutschland ja vier Mal äh so viele
Todesfälle pro Einwohner, wie in Dänemark, obwohl in Dänemark die Infektion äh deutlich höher liegen äh seit einer Weile, also.
Da scheint es auch deutliche Unterschiede zu geben und ja Holland wie gesagt trotz,
der vielen Infektionen, die sie hatten, äh stehen eigentlich auch ganz, ganz gut da. Während.
Wie gesagt, Österreich, Schweiz, A tödlich.
Gut, da lohnt sich dann vielleicht auch nochmal kurz auf die äh Kurvenverläufe zu schauen, wie die positiven Rate aussieht bei den Tests, da gibt's natürlich dann auch erhebliche Ausreißer, da ist nämlich Dänemark sehr niedrig derzeit, auch langsam steigend, aber die sind äh noch unter fünf Prozent
ja ähm für Deutschland sind die Zahlen hier ein bisschen älter, aber wir liegen ja derzeit so bei elf zehn,
Prozent und ähm wenn man jetzt mal aufs andere Ende guckt, dann liegt dann Tschechien, mal locker schon bei zwanzig, einundzwanzig, zweiundzwanzig Prozent,
Polen bei vierunddreißig Prozent und zwischenzeitlich waren die schon mal bei fünfzig Prozent. Also es alles sehr unterschiedlich.
Ähm was da so an Potential drin ist, ne? Wie gesagt, positiven Rate sagt so ein bisschen was darüber aus, wie sehr man den anderen Zahlen glauben darf,
So würde ich das mal interpretieren.
Das heißt, wenn da äh Kurven hochgehen, dann entsprechen die gewisser Hinsicht die der Wahrheit und äh äh Polen darf man derzeit sozusagen überhaupt nichts glauben.
Ja äh und bei den Toten sind sie ja zum Beispiel auch relativ weit äh äh oben. Also es ist.
Wie immer hier gibt's keine klaren Aussagen, aber muss halt mal schauen äh dass alle hier irgendwie klar kommen.
Jo dann haben wir den Zahlenbereich erstmal so weit durch. Ja, jetzt haben wir hier unseren.
Lokdown, unseren sogenannten, hast du schon was davon gemerkt.
Na ja, also,
Es ist mehr so ein Selbstlogdown, äh, würde ich sagen, den ich durchführe, aber an sich, ich mein, ich kann rausgehen, wann ich will.
Ich kann treffen, wen ich will und wesentlichen auch, wo ich will und also ja.
Für bist du die die Kontrollen auf der Straße, die Straßensperren.
Na ja ich mein ich persönlich vermisse sie nicht,
aber so ja es ist halt eine Menge los und meine viele Leute müssen nach wie vor auch außer Haus
arbeiten, ich glaub zehn oder zwanzig Prozent der Schüler werden auch noch betreut und gehen halt auch dann irgendwohin.
Es wurden auch in Berlin zum Beispiel äh noch bis heute noch Arbeiten geschrieben. Also die haben zwar die Schulen zugemacht,
den Unterricht beendet, aber die Klassenarbeiten, die halt jetzt für die letzte Woche gescannt waren, die wollten sie noch durchziehen. Was.
Nachvollziehbar ist insofern als das äh,
Ne, dass da sozusagen jetzt nochmal so eine extra Disruption wäre, diese Winterferien dann eben nicht zur Bewertung von Klassenarbeiten und so weiter. Das staut sich ja immer so gegen Ende des Jahres, ist klar, sowas so von Winterferien, hast du halt nochmal arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten und das ist ja auch teilweise sehr wichtig
um auf Noten zu kommen, um Empfehlungen fürs nächste Schuljahr abzugeben und so weiter. Das ist halt genau die Zeit, wo sich im Prinzip so der äh der Schulwechsel,
für bestimmte Jahrgänge zumindest abzeichnet, ne? Und wichtige vor Noten erfasst werden, um halt so das Zwischenzeugnis zu machen und deswegen haben sie hal
gefragt, ob sie das noch tun dürfen, also haben sich dann irgendwie eine Aula gesetzt und mit Abstand und so weiter halt klar. Ist nicht dasselbe wie Unterricht so. Äh wäre sicherlich jetzt auch ähm
schöner gewesen, man hätte das auch noch weggelassen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt am Ende wirklich das Kernproblem ist.
Ne, wahrscheinlich ist das nicht das Kernproblem, ist natürlich immer alles Abwägungssache, aber so andere Untersuchungen liegen auch nahe, dass so schon ein selbst ein Tag.
Später eine Maßnahme ergreifen,
doch erhebliche Auswirkungen haben kann, je nachdem wie stark die Zahlen auch gerade im steigen begriffen sind. Und das Irreste aber ist.
Was mir gar nicht so klar war als Berliner.
Können wir sogar nach Polen fahren zum Einkaufen, zum Beispiel um Feuerwerk einzukaufen für.
Silvester und es gibt sogar zehn Reisebusse, die täglich zur Einkaufstour nach Polen fahren von Berlin aus.
Und äh das alles ist deswegen möglich, weil's halt eine Ausnahmeregelung.
In der Berliner Corona Schutzverordnung, die besagt, dass man für einen Tag.
Ins Ausland darf, also wenn man sich länger als vierundzwanzig Stunden in dem Risikogebiet aufhält und nach Berlin zurückkehrt, braucht man nicht in Quarantäne.
Dass äh gilt aber nicht in Brandenburg, sodass wir halt jetzt die perverse Situation haben, dass Berliner,
legal in Polen einkaufen können, aber Brandenburger nicht. So. Das ist natürlich ja ganz toll.
Geil und dann alle in Busse. Super Idee. Oh Mann ey.
Also mit anderen Worten selbst,
Wenn der erste Logdown oder wie auch immer wir das nennen, der das Maßnahmenbündel. Nennen wir es einfach mal Maßnahmenbündel vom ähm zweiten November,
man mit dem Attribut leid versehen will, dann ist das jetzt im Sinne, sagen wir jetzt der Sprudelklassifizierung bestenfalls Medium.
Noch nicht mal Classic oder so.
Der lockt da und zischt gar nicht.
Zischt nicht wirklich.
Plus äh wie gesagt, dass wir halt ja auch ein weitgehendes Vollzugs.
Defizit haben am Ende ähm ist das, was jetzt so.
Da ist auch im, ich sage mal Medium Maßnahmenbündel kaum zu kontrollieren. Ich meine ja.
Wie soll's gehen? Und äh in anderen Ländern hat man das da deutlich strikter gemacht, da,
gab's halt Kontrollen auf der Straße und da durftest du dich nicht mehr als ein Kilometer von deiner Wohnung wegbewegen und wenn doch, dann
musstest du halt einen Schein vorweisen von deinem Arbeitgeber, dass du auf dem Weg zur Arbeit bist und zurück und musst dich dann aber auch auf direktem Wege
dahin begeben und so und.
Ja, man mag sein, vielleicht in dem einen oder anderen Landkreis habe ich auch schon sowas gehört, dass Leute mit einem Ordnungsgeld.
Belegt worden sind, aber meistens, weil sie sich geweigert haben, eine Maske aufzusetzen. Ach so, ja, selbst wenn du keine trägst, ist es oft so, wenn du dann, wenn jemand kommt und sagt,
setzt die Maske auf und man zieht die auf, selbst dann kommt man wahrscheinlich in der Regel ohne Ordnungsgeld. Äh davon, was ich jetzt auch nicht verkehrt finde.
Aber.
Man kann festhalten von der Obrigkeitshörigkeit, es sind Preußen nicht viel übrig geblieben.
Ja. Also gut, man man wird sehen äh wie.
Sehr die Leute sich jetzt dran halten oder nicht, aber wenn ich so auf die Straßen gucke oder so,
so richtig ruhig wie im April ähm
Ist es noch nicht, wie man es ist, ruhiger geworden, aber tagsüber, die Straßen sind voll
in den Bussen sitzen Leute, in den U-Bahnen sitzen Leute, also ja, da da ist noch Luft, da ist noch Luft nach oben und es kann auch gut sein,
dass wir äh diese Luft auch brauchen werden. Muss man leider auch ehrlich sagen.
Man kriegt, glaube ich, diese Weihnachtsaktivität aus den Leuten irgendwie nicht raus.
Das ist das wahrscheinlich ein Problem, aber wie gesagt, viele Leute auch äh müssen halt arbeiten äh gehen.
Können nicht im Homeoffice arbeiten und das zieht natürlich 'n riesen Rattenschwanz hinter sich her, dann brauchen Sie Kinderbetreuung und dann ähm ja müssen viele auch mit dem öffentlichen,
Kehrsmitteln fahren und sitzen in Büros zusammen oder äh ja dann Lieferdienste natürlich. So.
Wobei ich jetzt nicht glaube, dass das ein super Risiko ist, aber na ja, weppert sich halt alles.
Du hast ja auch noch so eine Studie angeschaut, ne? So, was sind so die Maßnahmen bewirken? Äh.
Ja, es gab, genau, es gab noch wieder jetzt eine ganz ja, eine neue äh äh Studie so vom.
Karlsruhe Institut of Technology und es ist ein Priprint muss man auch dazu sagen und das Ganze ist vom Institut für Wirtschaftsinformatik und Marketing, das ist jetzt auch von ersten
Blick jetzt auch nicht so vertrauen, erweckend und ich hab jetzt auch Daten und Code nicht gefunden, vielleicht sind die,
irgendwo draußen oder sie werden sie noch rausstellen, aber sofern.
Ja ist das Ergebnis mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber ich fand die Idee.
Einfach ganz interessant äh nämlich,
den Ansatz namens Concept Drift äh zu benutzen. Ich wusste jetzt gar nicht, dass es die Namen hat, aber ähm so mir war das Phänomen schon,
bewusst und zwar stammt es aus dem Bereich Maschinenlearning und neuronale Netze.
Und zwar ist es so, wenn man jetzt Daten hat, kann man halt ja.
Sag mal neuronales Netz ganz gut darauf trainieren. Ähm sich diese Datenreihenfolge anzuschauen und dann von sich aus äh diese.
Daten weiter in die Zukunft fortzuschreiben, also sagen zu lernen mh was da passiert im Hintergrund. Aber.
Also nehmen wir mal einen Aktienkurse so. Man zeigt den Dingen über mehrere Jahre Aktienkurse und lässt es dann die Aktienkurse vorhersagen.
Und das funktioniert halt alles auch ganz gut.
Bis sich halt irgendwas fundamentales ändert, also im Fall der Aktienkurse meinetwegen Housing Bubble oder Nine Eleven oder irgendeinen Ereignis plötzlich was.
Dass in den Trainingsdaten noch nicht gegeben hat und wo dann auf einmal,
die realen Zahlen und das, was das Modell berechnet, auseinanderlaufen und die haben in dem Paper halt,
Drifterkennung, also zu gucken, wann.
Läuft denn das Modell, was ich trainiert habe und die Zahlen? Wann sind die denn auseinandergelaufen.
Als es diese nicht medizinischen Interventionen gab und haben.
Dann versucht so die die Auswirkungen dann ab dem Punkt,
auch zu berechnen und sind dabei auf relativ spektakuläre Ergebnisse gekommen, was Schulen betrifft und deren These ist, dass,
sagen, ein Tag spätere Schulschließungen im März hm die Zahl der Gesamtinfektionen verdoppelt hätten und eine Woche spätere Schulschließungen vervierfacht hätten.
Ähm ich würde jetzt diese Zahlen nicht.
Unterschreiben wollen, weil ich habe das, wie gesagt, nicht nachgerechnet und äh dazu fehlen mir auch viele Details, aber.
Das grundsätzliche Prinzip nämlich, dass wenn ich später interveniere.
Zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo die Zahlen auf dem Weg nach oben sind, dann.
Sind es nicht nur die zusätzlichen Infektionen in der Zeit,
abwarte sondern die sind ja inzwischen nach oben gegangen, das heißt die müssen dann halt auch erst wieder nach unten gehen, das heißt ich habe halt, wenn ich einen Tag warte ähm.
Später mache, habe ich halt Nummer drei oder vier Tage lang erhöhte Zahlen oder,
es kann beliebig lange dauern, bis sie halt wieder runter äh gehen so und all das geht dann auf Kosten dieses einen Tagesverzögerung, das heißt es ist durchaus möglich, dass wenn man,
Maßnahmen einen Tag später trifft, dass äh ja dann je nachdem wie wie schnell
sie hinterher wieder runtergehen, dass einen Tag wirklich eine Verdoppelung ausmacht. Ob das jetzt im April tatsächlich der Fall war, weiß ich nicht, aber mich hat das auf jeden Fall inspiriert. Ich werde mal ein paar,
Grafen machen und das mal ein bisschen durchrechnen, was es denn bedeutet, ähm sagen ein Tag.
Zwei Tage, eine Woche, zwei Wochen später zu intervenieren bei.
Einem ja R von und dann zu gucken äh wie um wie viel das denn äh die Zahlen äh dann vervielfacht. So, dann haben wir mal eine Übersicht und dann auch wissen und wir wissen halt auch.
Das jetzt Schulschließungen zwischen zehn und fünfundzwanzig Prozent typischerweise ähm,
den R-Faktor reduzieren und äh ja habe ich wenigstens einen Plausibilitätstest dafür.
Aber es ist halt auch wieder ein weiterer Datenpunkt zumindest oder einen einen Indiz ähm.
Dass ja Schulen doch eine relevante Rolle spielen und doch sehr starken Einfluss auf die Zahlenentwicklung haben können.
Ja, wenn die Zahlen denn immer äh so stimmen, die man überhaupt hat, ne? Äh es muss sich hier nochmal was äh sagen. Wir hatten letzte Woche,
ähm ein Teil hier besprochen, den ich dann im im Schnitt rausgenommen habe,
Das äh ist jetzt in den letzten Wochen schon ein paar Mal passiert und zwar meistens immer dann, wenn wir dann festgestellt haben, während wir über irgendwas gesprochen haben,
dass uns dann am Ende doch so ein bisschen die Evidenz äh fehlt oder die Zahlen irgendwie nicht so richtig stimmen und bevor wir so halb
gares Zeug hier raushauen, versuchen wir das natürlich dann auch eher zu vermeiden. Und ich hatte dann in meiner Liste äh einen Artikel über Boris Palma, den Bürgermeister von Tübingen äh dabei,
Wir haben da auch kurz drüber gesprochen, weil er hat sich ja weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt und äh gesagt, so na ja, also wir schützen ja hier unsere Alten ganz total super und wir hatten ja hier in den letzten paar Wochen überhaupt gar keine Fälle.
Und ich habe das dann erstmal so ähm wie er es gesagt hat mit in die Sendung genommen und dann hat Pavel in seine Zahlen reingeschaut und so das passte dann irgendwie überhaupt
nicht mit den Zahlen und das war dann so der Punkt, wo ich mir dachte so, okay, das ist jetzt einfach zum Fischi. Irgendwie
lieber nächste Woche nochmal machen, kommen wir dann die Sendung raus, kam's dann irgendwie auch schon in den Nachrichten so, ja, dass alle mal nachgeschaut haben und Boris Palmer musste mittlerweile zurückrudern und seine Aussagen haben halt einfach nicht gestimmt. Also ich meine, war wohl generell so, dass es in Tübingen bisschen besser aussah
aber die Feststellung mit, sie hätten jetzt bei den Plus fünfundsiebzig Jährigen seit Wochen keine Fälle äh gehabt, das war halt einfach falsch.
Das war massiv übertrieben, aber sagen beim,
beim Draufgucken sah es so aus ja das schon die Fälle, ich sag mal halb so viele waren wie ähm so in Berlin zum Beispiel so die Institution.
Waren deutlich besser so, aber äh ja das, was er da von sich gegeben hat, war weit, weit übertrieben und das ist natürlich schon verdammt peinlich.
Ja, ist peinlich, obwohl es ja an sich ähm,
lobenswerte Maßnahmen war, die angeschoben wurden, ne? Also das waren so Sachen wie äh ähm die die Läden dazu zu bringen
besondere Einkaufszeiten für ältere Leute auszuschreiben. Das ist ja auch so 'ne Idee die glau
ganz früh in Italien schon umgesetzt wurden, sowas wohl dazu geführt hat, dass dann eben auch wirklich die Leute ohne, dass jetzt ein Zwang angeordnet wurde, die Supermärkte quasi erst so ab elf Uhr beschritten haben und dann eben so von neun bis elf Uhr für Ältere
das freigehalten wurde und was sie auch noch ganz charmant fand die Idee dass sie die Kosten übernommen haben für Taxifahrten.
Für ältere Leute, die dann eben nicht mit dem Bus fahren mussten, sondern könnten quasi stattdessen ein Taxi alleine nehmen und der Mehrpreis, der dadurch entstanden ist, den hat halt dann die äh Stadt abgedeckt, ne? Und
ja, Schnelltest und so weiter, aber auch hier zeigt sich wieder, man kann noch so viel machen, dass eigentlich so ein bisschen die Lehre da draus, man kann.
Diese Forderung, die ja immer mal wieder in den Diskussionen auftaucht mit na ja, wenn wir nur die Alten schützen, dann ist schon irgendwie alles super.
Ja, das funktioniert äh so irgendwie ähm nicht wirklich. Das das ist so ohne Weiteres einfach nicht zu realisieren und das muss man dann irgendwie auch mal äh verstehen.
Ja, wobei ich glaube, dass das halt auch an ja unterschiedlicher Ausstattung der Heime ein bisschen liegt. Sicherlich spielt auch Glück.
Mit rein, aber ich denke, es gibt Heime, wo es besser funktioniert und andere, wo es halt
einfach schlechter funktioniert und wahrscheinlich diejenigen, die schon, ich sage mal, vor Corona schon auf dem Zahnfleischöl liefen, da kann man auch einfach nicht erwarten, dass sie in der Lage sind,
so eine Krise dann wirklich zuwettern. Äh so und.
Ja was jetzt Palma betrifft, äh wer halt besser gewesen, der einfach gesagt hätte, hier die Maßnahmen und äh wir haben damit.
Es geschafft, äh sagen die Sterblichkeit deutlich zu reduzieren.
Was man wahrscheinlich sogar belegen kann, also auf den ersten Blick sah es jedenfalls so aus, äh dass die Zahlen äh nicht schlecht waren so, also im Inzidenzvergleich auch ähm ja,
der Unterschied zwischen anderen Altersgruppen deutlich weniger ausgeprägt als in Berlin zum Beispiel.
Und insofern äh ja äh hätte er einfach jetzt nicht übertrieben äh.
Wer das wahrscheinlich besser gewesen, aber äh ja, die Maßnahmen klingen sinnvoll und haben wahrscheinlich durchaus was gebracht, nur nicht das, was er versprochen hat.
Hat sich mal auf jeden Fall persönlich jetzt nicht viel äh gehofft, äh äh ist ja äh mit den Grünen seiner Partei schon so ein bisschen äh auf Reibungsprogramm äh stets gewesen und äh
die Nummer sorgt jetzt wieder für äh entsprechenden Aufruhr, ob's reicht, ihn da abzusägen oder ob das auch nur angemessen ist, will ich gar nicht beurteilen, das werden wir dann sehen, das äh.
Gewisse Possenhaftigkeit hat, hat diese Geschichte schon, ne?
Definitiv. Ja, ansonsten.
Grad schon dabei sind so ähm weil wir haben nämlich ganz vergessen bei den bei den.
Fällen glaube ich noch, wie es denn mich jetzt weiter äh geht eigentlich,
und äh weil ja schon wieder diese Lockerungsorgiendiskussion laufen, so nach dem Motto, na ja und dann
zehnten Januar machen wir die Schulen wieder auf so und ich mein nicht,
nicht überall, es gibt auch ganz viele Stimmen in der Politik, die sagen, wir wissen nicht, einfach nicht bis wann, das kann lange dauern so, aber es gibt halt auch die Kandidaten, die schon jetzt wieder,
nach Lockerungen rufen und Versprechen, dass die Zahlen bis zehnten Januar wieder äh runtergehen so, aber.
Dafür gibt's halt überhaupt kein.
Anlass oder Ausgangspunkt. Ich hab ja jetzt im letzten Monat immer wieder mal meine Grafik aktualisiert, wo ich so verschiedene Ehrwerte.
Die Kurven eingezeichnet habe und wann man denn dann unter fünfzig kommt.
Im Moment sind wir auf der eins einser Kurve, das ist die steilste Anstiegkurve, die ich dort berücksichtigt hatte.
Und da bewegen wir uns jetzt gerade lang und damit wir bis äh Januar, also bis irgendwann im Januar äh auf unter fünfzig äh.
Kommen müssten wir ab sofort einen R-Wert von unter null Komma acht haben.
So von eins Komma eins auf null Komma acht sind so null Komma drei oder etwas über äh ja dreißig Prozent äh die man.
Runter kommen muss und,
da sehe ich im Moment nicht, wo das Herkommen soll in der Summe bei unserem,
Lokdown, Medium und mit Weihnachten und Silvester vor der Tür können wir froh sein,
wenn wir überhaupt einen Plateau erreichen oder geringfügig unter eins äh kommen und ja mit anderen Worten es ist völlig ungewiss, wann.
Wir ja auf Institzen runterkommen, wo man ernsthaft über Lockerungen reden kann.
Also wenn's rein nach den Zahlen geht, würde ich sagen, ja äh dieser.
Lokdown Medium wahrscheinlich bis.
April oder Mai und wenn wir nochmal nachlegen, dann vielleicht bis Februar oder März so, ne? Ähm na ja, wenn einzelne Bundesländer könnten halt.
Eher runterkommen, äh aber Diskussionen hatten wir ja, äh die sind gerade auch eher auf dem aufsteigenden Ast.
Ja, jetzt wird's halt so teuer, wie wir das immer befürchtet haben, ne? Das äh so so zeichnet sich das jetzt ab.
Genau und und noch ein so ein Ding, was mir aufgefallen ist.
Wenn man jetzt, ich sage mal, verschieden starke Lokdowns kombinieren muss, u.
Die Zahlen runterzukriegen, dann macht man am besten zuerst natürlich den allerhärtesten.
Den man irgendwie nur sich vorstellen kann und wenn die Zahlen dann runter sind, dann kann man.
Langsam überlockern, nachdenken und langsamer reduzieren, ja. Was aber total bekloppt ist, ist wie wir das machen in der umgekehrten Reihenfolge. Wir fangen halt jetzt mit so,
leibt an, lassen die Zahlen erstmal nach oben gehen, beziehungsweise senken sie nicht, äh warten dann ab
bis die Zahlen wieder anfangen zu steigen und dann wieder jetzt Medium einzuführen, dass sich die Zahlen auf einem noch höheren Niveau äh stabilisieren, wo,
einfach halt jede Menge Leute sterben. So, das ist das ist halt.
Einfach das Ding plus, das natürlich, wenn du diese drei Logdowns, die im Endeffek.
Lasst die drei Logdowns so äh jeweils drei oder vier Wochen dauern und je nach Härteleitmedium hart so und so viel Kosten hat, ist teuer.
Medium ist mittelteuer und leid ist am wenigsten teuer, so wenn ich die jetzt in der einen Reihenfolge äh kombiniere,
dann kriege ich halt ich weiß nicht, zehn Mal so viel Bank for the Back, ja? Dann ist das halt viel billiger, wenn ich erst mit dem Harten anfange und dann mit dem langsam als so wie wir es machen. Ja, so wie wir's machen, ist es teuer,
dauert alles länger oder wenn man halt einen festen Preis ist.
Bereit zu zahlen, dann kriegen wir halt für das Geld, was wir zahlen einfach mit der verkehrten Reihenfolge viel, viel weniger.
Ja, das ist wirklich das, was einen so ein bisschen äh fassungslos macht. Was, was es ja noch weiter verschlimmert ist und das sieht man ja derzeit auch,
Jetzt hatten wir so unseren Lokdown Light und der ist dann so gegen Ende dann schon stark ausgefranst. Und dann, wenn sozusagen die Leute schon so kein Bock mehr haben.
Dann äh zu sagen, oh okay, jetzt aber nochmal ein bisschen härter.
Fahren sie alle, wie war's jetzt noch härter? Äh geht doch schon so lange. Also.
Man bestraft sozusagen immer mehr und und wird muss noch mehr Aufwand treiben,
um auch die entsprechende Compliance zu bekommen. Und das andere ist auch, das war vielleicht auch noch so ein bisschen so ein Fehler, dieses Loch downlight. Man hat gesagt, na ja okay, jetzt mal so zwei Wochen und dann schauen wir mal.
War im Prinzip zwei Wochen Compliance und danach,
Schauen wir mal, hat gar keiner mehr mitbekommen. Da äh hat es dann im Prinzip schon nachgelassen, das lässt sich ja auch an den Zahlen relativ klar ablesen.
Aber es wurde nie kommuniziert, was ist denn nun sozusagen eigentlich der Bewertungsgrund, ja? Sonst wurde immer nur so, dass, dann schauen wir nochmal und dann bewerten wir nochmal, aber was bewertet wird und was der Freshhold ist, um
diese Bewertung so oder so ausgehen zu lassen wurde nicht genannt.
Und würde man das zum Beispiel an diesen Institzen einfach klar machen und sagen, wir machen jetzt einfach so lange
bis der Erde auf null Komma sieben ist. So, das wäre zumindest schon mal, ne? Also bis wir sozusagen so bis die Kurve soweit runtergeht so. Und dann halten wir noch lange so lange durch
bis ähm.
Oder oder dann gibt es gewisse Lockerungen, aber die müssen quasi äh doch so lange gehalten werden, bis wir dann mit der Insidenz auch äh in so einem Zielbereich sind. Und dann ist es vorbei und dann wissen alle, worauf man hinarbeitet.
So, man kann quasi täglich gucken, wie lange dauert's denn noch? Ah nee, Institution ist noch zu hoch. Äh Kurve geht noch nicht schnell genug runter und dann dann wissen alle,
quasi was sie dafür tun können, damit's vorbei ist. Und so wird's halt einfach immer nur so nach oben lamentiert. Ja, wieso ist denn noch nicht vorbei.
Eigentlich ja ist das beste Rezept in dem Moment.
Wo einem die Entwicklung entgleitet.
Und das ist bei uns so am ja Mitte Oktober war das.
Klar erkennbar äh so wir haben wir haben die Zahlen nicht mehr im Griff, die Institzen sind,
bundesweit so zwischen dem vierzehnten und einundzwanzigsten äh über fünfzig gestiegen. Das war so.
Der Punkt, wo man hätte mit einem sofortigen,
maximal harten Lokdown rangehen müssen, Schulen zu, Geschäfte zu.
Kontrollen Quarantäne äh so ganze Shibangen.
Und dann äh ja.
Dann hätte man äh wahrscheinlich auch äh nach vier Wochen äh äh oder nach vier bis sechs Wochen also.
Jetzt äh werden wir dann wahrscheinlich wieder unter den fünfzig gewesen. Klar, kann man nicht sicher sagen, aber was wir wissen, ist, dass,
ein harter Logdown sehr wohl wirkt, wenn er denn auch kontrolliert wird.
Und ja das ist einfach versäumt worden und jetzt zahlen wir leider.
Den Preis und äh ja ich rechne damit.
Dass äh nochmal eine Runde nachgelegt wird, bevor irgendwie irgendwann Lockerungen kommen können. Also ich.
Glaub halt.
Nicht, dass das jetzt ausreichen wird, um die Zahlen zu senken, plus das Problem, was wir haben, ist es jetzt über Weihnachten, wenn's.
Ärzte und Ämter und Labore sehr unregelmäßig arbeiten werden, wahrscheinlich.
Wobei glücklicherweise habe ich jetzt die Weihnachtsfeiertage sehr arbeit.
Geberfreundlich äh liegen, sodass äh das vielleicht in Grenzen hält, aber äh wir werden auch.
Probleme kriegen, wirklich zu sehen, wie entwickelt sich denn jetzt die Infektion überhaupt äh ja.
Stimmt das wissen wir wahrscheinlich auch erst so langsam in der ersten Januarwoche, ja? Weil wenn sie äh alle wieder so ein bisschen aus ihren Löchern äh rauskriechen. Na ja gut, das wird äh noch spannend sein, das zu sehen.
Lass uns mal auf ein paar andere Sachen ähm wechseln. Hm, ich habe noch so ein paar,
Meldungen, paar Sachen, die ich mir ein bisschen länger angeschaut habe. Ähm, vielleicht vorweg nochmal so auch als Nachtrag zu dieser Debatte, die wir ja hatten, mit gab's äh seit wann gibt's denn dieses Virus eigentlich schon wirklich, ne? Das äh,
ist ja noch sehr umstritten. Das hat jetzt nochmal interessante Nahrung bekommen und zwar,
wurde in Italien aus dieser Region Bürgermo äh neben stimmt gar nicht Mailand ähm.
Da gab's halt einen Fall eines vierjährigen Jungen, der hatte halt so äh Atembeschwerden und da ist halt auch eine eine Probe genommen worden, die sie sich jetzt nochmal genauer angeschaut haben und bei dem
Kind konnte halt auch äh saß Kopf zwei wohl sicher nachgewiesen werden. Das ist also jetzt verlasse mich jetzt sozusagen auf diesen Bericht, ja, dass sie sich da,
äh mal äh sicher sind. Was sagt uns das? Das sagt,
dass es sehr wohl sein kann, dass das Virus eben schon im November dort angeschwemmt wurde. Es gibt ja diese relativ starke
China und Norditalien, die da so ein bisschen überhaupt so die Brücke erstmal war für Europa nach China und es ist natürlich klar, also wenn
Probleme in China Ende Dezember aufgetreten sind und es wurde ja da am Anfang auch noch so ein bisschen vor sich hin,
bevor es dann äh richtig öffentlich wurde, kann man davon ausgehen, dass das halt irgendwie alles das Geschehen irgendwie alles so im November äh seinen Anfang genommen hat, ne? Oder
Oktober vielleicht,
kann man eben nicht genau sagen. So und dann ist es unter Umständen mindestens bei diesem einen Fall relativ früh rüber geschwappt. Man wusste jetzt bei dem Jungen auch, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt, woher es hatte, also es muss dann auch schon nochmal die eine oder andere Ecke äh gegangen sein.
Also das nur mal so als Information nebenbei, ihr wisst ja, all diese ganzen Studien und Meldungen, die wir hier äh nennen, sind alle in den Shownotes verlinkt, sollte irgendwas nicht in den Shownotes verlinkt sein, bitte sofort beschweren, dann äh war das bestimmt nur kurz äh was übersehen, aber,
jetzt hier nicht einfach irgendwas, sondern wir suchen uns das natürlich hier auch ganz unprofessionell aus dem Netz zusammen,
Genau, genauso.
Quelle, Quelle in.
Quelle, Internet, geht auch. Immer die beste Quelle ah ja dann schaue ich mir auch so.
Studien an und versucht die mit meinem eingeschränkten medizinischen Wissen zu verstehen.
Ja, da ist mir eine äh Studie aufgefallen, wo das,
Ganze mal genetisch untersucht wurde, was es denn vielleicht für Gründe hat, dass die Verläufe.
Schweren Verläufe bei neunzehn Krankheit ähm ja
ebenso unterschiedlich sind. So und das ist eine bei Nature veröffentlichte Studie und was sie da gemacht haben ist, dass sie Patienten ähm,
die halt schwer erkrankt waren,
genauer untersucht haben, also das Ganze war eine Studie der University of Adambra, da haben sie irgendwie zweitausendzweihundertvierundvierzig schwerkranke Patienten aus insgesamt zweihundertacht
britischen Intensivstationen untersucht.
Und haben dort halt äh DNA Proben entnommen, also passiert das nur im Rahmen dieser Studie gemacht haben oder ob das dann generell äh äh getan wurden, die es einfach nur eingesammelt haben. Also auf jeden Fall haben sie sich diese DNA dieser Leute angeschaut,
Und
haben das Ganze verglichen mit ähm entsprechender Kontrolle einer entsprechenden Kontrollgruppe
die man so heutzutage aus der entsprechenden Gendatenbank entnehmen kann. Das heißt, man geht in so eine Datenbank rein und sagt, okay, gib mal hier eine genauso verteilte Kontrollgruppe von irgendwelchen äh Leuten
Bei dem man dann aber noch sichergestellt hat, dass die mittlerweile nicht auch an Covet erkrankt sind, ja? Also sozusagen Leuten, die das irgendwie nicht haben, damit man dann eben gucken kann,
ist hier in der von der Krankheit betroffenen Gruppe irgendeine Genkombination,
häufiger vertreten, gibt's hier irgendwas, was darauf hinweisen könnte, dass das hier eine genetische Disposition vorliegt, die Leute für diese Krankheit anfälliger machen.
Und dabei hat man an äh verschiedene Erkrankungsformen auch äh drauf geachtet. Also es gibt da was weiß ich, die Unterscheidung nach erstmal grippalen Symptomen, Fieber
Schöpfung, Husten ist so eine Kategorie, dann Schnupfensymptome, also Schnupfen, Niesen, trockener Hals, verstopfte Nase
dann gibt's die Kategorie Gelenk, Muskelschmerzen, die Kategorie Augen und Schleimhautentzündungen.
'ne weitere Lungenprobleme, also Lungenentzündung, Kurzatmigkeit, dann Magen-Darm-Probleme, also Durchfall, Übelübelkeit und damit verbundene Kopfschmerzen und äh
besonders der Klassiker ja überhaupt Verlust des Geruch und Geschmackssinns.
Ja? Also das sind sozusagen die Sachen, nach denen sie dann geschaut haben und haben das eben versucht, mit diesen
Genvarianten zu vergleichen und äh stellt sich raus. Tatsächlich gab's so fünf Gengruppen, die bei diesen Patienten,
häufiger in irgendeiner Form auftraten oder in veränderter Form auftraten. Ähm also.
Da waren dann so Sachen dabei äh Schwächungen der Immunabwehr.
Also wenn äh so bestimmte genetische Kombinationen, die dazu führt, dass halt die Immunabwehr äh geschwächt ist. Es wird sicherlich weniger äh überraschend so, dass ähm.
Hat halt zu schwereren Verläufen geführt, weil die einfach die Immunimmunreaktion des Körpers nicht entsprechend äh stark war und Gene die ähm Entzündung.
Bevorzugen. Das war dann sozusagen auch noch so ein ein Auslöser.
Wofür ist das jetzt interessant? Ist jetzt erstmal eine rein medizinische Geschichte aber sie meinen,
In dieser Studie, dass das eben Gene sind, die man so in der Summe häufiger findet bei Menschen afrikanischer Abstammung.
Und das könnte unter Umständen die gehäuften Fälle bei bei schwarzen.
Erklären, die sowohl in USA als auch wohl in United Kingdom aufgetreten sind. Also es ist sozusagen auch da nochmal eine andere äh Disposition gibt.
Ja
Ja man.
Für die auch mal überflogen äh die Studie und was halt auffällig ist, ist das doch äh das ein sehr, sehr großes Team.
War, dass äh diese Studie durchgeführt hat und auch.
Na gut, alle Leute genannt sind, die äh bestimmte.
Gene. Ähm dort oder Gensequenzen beigesteuert haben und so, aber,
alleine, ich glaube, die hatten allein zehn Leute, äh die mit der Datenaufbereitung beschäftigt waren oder so, die.
Genannt sind. Insofern ja sieht es jetzt auf den ersten Blick äh auch wenn ich mir hier die.
Daten äh anschaue.
Mich jetzt aufn aufn ersten Blick nichts gefunden, wo ich sagen würde, das sieht aus wie Quatsch oder es sieht aus wie Unsinn. Gut, auf der anderen Seite.
Ist es jetzt auch keine allzu verwegene Vermutung äh dass es vermutlich.
Allen Krankheiten so, dass äh Gene äh eine Rolle spielen wie.
Man mit bestimmten Erregern klar kommt oder nicht und.
Was gut passiert. Natürlich glaube ich nicht gemacht.
Jetzt zu gucken, ob das bei anderen Krankheiten anders ist, aber wahrscheinlich kriegst du bei anderen Krankheiten.
Auch gar nicht diese Zahlen zusammen, dass so diese Untersuchungen so überhaupt machen kannst. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder.
Bisschen so ein spezielles Ding, was darauf basiert, äh dass wir erstmalig so unglaublich.
Viele Erkrankte äh haben, an denen man Studien durchführen kann, jedenfalls im Westen. China,
haben sie halt eher das Problem, dass sie halt ins Ausland fahren müssen jetzt um Corona weiter zu studieren, weil sie dort einfach nicht genügend Fälle äh haben.
Oder auch nur ihre Impfstoffe ordentlich.
Um allein schon ihre Impfstoffe testen zu können, ja.
Genau. Warum habe ich das jetzt äh erwähnt? Also es gab ja äh in den USA auch äh tatsächlich gehäufte Zahlen bei bei schwarzen.
Und die lassen sich sicherlich auch teilweise eben sozial erklären, ne? Also,
sogenannten Essential Workers, ne? Also haben wir jetzt auch eine neue Vorstellung davon, so Pa
Dienste et cetera. Also so Dienste, die dann eben nicht von zu Hause arbeiten können und so weiter, die natürlich dann auch überproportional von Schwarzen durchgeführt wurden und da kann man natürlich dann auch schnell rausrechnen, okay, die sind dann halt in solchen Berufen, sind dann entsprechend mehr gefährdet, dann eben auch m,
betroffen. Ich habe jetzt mir die Zahlen als als solche nicht angeschaut und ja äh letztlich kann man nur sagen,
gibt hier zumindest noch eine zweite Komponente. Es mag halt auch tatsächlich äh genetische Dispositionen geben oder zumindest ist hier mal ein klarer Anhaltspunkt gefunden worden. Einer ähm,
der wirklich gemessen werden konnte und es mag auch noch andere geben, auf die wir äh in Zukunft noch stoßen oder vielleicht schon mal irgendjemand drauf gestoßen äh ist. Ähm.
Wenn man also versucht Erklärungen für solche Verteilungen zu finden, muss man vermutlich auch noch ein paar Studien abwarten.
Wahrscheinlich kommt man,
man mit solchen Ergebnissen, wenn die sich erhärten, könnte man natürlich theoretisch auch einen äh Gentest machen, der,
dir dann sagt, wie wahrscheinlich bei dir ein schwerer Verlauf wäre, aber ich,
aus, dass ein solcher Test ein vielfaches von Dieb kosten würde, was eine Impfung kostet.
Oh, das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, zumal es ja äh letzten Endes geht's ja nur darum, ob da ein Genitscher Kot bekannt ist so und wenn man dieses diese Genhäuferung jetzt einfach so feststellen kann,
unter Umständen äh dann gehen Material schon auch in irgendeiner Datenbank. Ich meine, es gibt ja mittlerweile private Dienstleister, da kannst du da von dir eine eine Haut äh oder Haarprobe oder so hinschick
dann wird halt da deine DNA extrahiert und bewertet und dann kriegst du schon erzählt wer so deine Vorfahren wahrscheinlich gewesen sind und zu wie viel Prozent du pirat bist
aber.
Wikinger, ja.
In der Zukunft und wir haben ja jetzt auch äh
letzten Sendung oder was die vorletzte auch über so so Fortschritte äh äh jetzt im medizinischen Bereich damit Proteinfaltung und so weiter gesprochen
die sich ja auch aus Gehen ableiten lassen. Also ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir da sozusagen auch so äh andere Frühwarnsysteme noch,
bekommen, ne? Oder jetzt sagen wir mal auch durch solche Studien noch genauer gesagt werden kann, wer denn noch gefährdeter ist,
gerade wenn wir jetzt darüber diskutieren, das werden wir jetzt hier auch gleich tun wie ein Impfstoffrohr Rollout geht, ne? Also jetzt ist natürlich klar
Jetzt muss man erstmal die Alten und wir müssen irgendwie die die Central Walker und so weiter und die Ärzte und haste nicht gesehen äh machen nur wie gehst du dann halt weiter,
da könnten natürlich auch solche Ergebnisse eine Rolle spielen. Kommen wir doch mal zu dem Impfstoff äh Thema, ohne das geht's ja nicht,
ähm zunächst einmal ist der Biontech-Impfstoff, der ja in.
Und mittlerweile auch in USA und ich glaube in Barain Dubai und so weiter schon zugelassen ist und auch schon äh verimpft wird. Äh die Zulassung durch die EMA, also durch die europäische.
Zulassungsbehörde, das ist jetzt vorgezogen worden. Also ich hatte da
von berichtet, neunundzwanzigster Dezember war ursprünglich der Termin, an dem sie das alles absingen wollten. Das haben sie jetzt wohl um acht Tage vorgezogen auf den einundzwanzigsten Dezember
warum auch immer, also kann ich nicht sagen, ob das jetzt irgendwie politischer Druck war oder sie der Meinung waren, das kriegen sie auch schneller hin. Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall
soll wohl der Tag sein, an dem es dann
mehr oder weniger offiziell das Go geben wird. Ich meine, davon ist auszugehen, dass es dieses Go geben wird, aber es ist sicherlich sinnvoll, diesen Prozess nochmal komplett
ähm zu beschreiten und dann ja, dann kann's halt losgehen, Impfzentren werden aufgebaut.
Auch hier in meiner Nähe entstehen entsteht eins und ähm
dann wird sehr viel davon abhängen, wie die Impfstoffverfügbarkeit ist, wie die gut die Verteilung äh läuft, wie viel Freiwillige gefunden werden können und diese Impfzentren auch
aktiv zu betreiben und natürlich wie die Teilnahmebereitschaft aussieht. Also.
Ich denke mal, es wird noch ein bisschen dauern, bis das so in unsere Altersgruppe vorrückt. Ähm jetzt war ja auch davon die Rede, also
erste, was jetzt kommt, ist ja quasi so der EU, also Deutschlands EU-Anteil an den gesicherten ähm.
Dosierung von diesem Impfstoff und ich glaube, darüber hinaus hat Deutschland eigentlich für diesen Bion Techwirkstoff auch keine größeren Bestellungen gemacht. Also ich habe noch so eine.
Andere Zahl gesehen und dann geht das dann eigentlich eher in Richtung dieses Astra Cineca, Ochsford, Impfstoffs et cetera, also
erscheint mir noch ein wenig offen zu sein, mit welchem Impfstoff, in welchen Mengen Deutschland letztlich äh beliefert wird
und ja, ich hoffe, dass genug da ist und natürlich auch genug Kapazität in diesen Impfzentren dann stattfindet, um das, was da ist, auch ordnungsgemä
an äh die Frau in den Mann zu bringen.
Also man hört halt Widersprüchliches äh so. Gut in USA ist er bekannt geworden, dass Trump äh.
Bestimmte Optionen, äh die ihm angeboten worden sind, abgelehnt äh hat
und äh jetzt ist äh ja äh knapp wird, aber dasselbe habe ich halt auch von Deutschland gehört, dass man nicht die maximalen Optionen gezogen hat, äh sondern ja.
Sagen da auch Dinge abgelehnt hat, aber so richtig transparent ist das alles nicht. Was da passiert und auf EU-Ebene, also,
eigentlich, wie ich das gesehen habe, hat die EU-Kommission eigentlich im Auftrag der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten Lieferverträge abgeschlossen und ich.
So, das heißt ähm ja, sagen, es gibt eine europäische Einkaufsgemeinschaft.
Die gibt es, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall auch noch eine noch eine deutsche Einkaufsgemeinschaft. Äh Deutschland will hat zum Beispiel auch äh Dosen von ähm Kurwack in Aussicht, nur Cuvec ist halt noch nicht äh mit seiner Phase drei durch und deswegen
es halt noch ein bisschen dauern.
Also am Ende mein das das Spiel ist ja auch noch nicht zu Ende. Also es hängt ja auch sehr davon ab, was kann jetzt überhaupt produziert werden, wie gut laufen die Produktionen an, was sind so die Mengen
dann wird man sich wahrscheinlich noch so ein bisschen drum boxen, um das Zeug, was da ist, insbesondere natürlich um das, was jetzt auch schon äh zu funktionieren scheint, das konnte man ja vorher nicht wissen, wer jetzt irgendwie am schnellsten fertig sein würde mit allem, ne? Und ähm ja, also,
Ich bin da insgesamt bin ich relativ entspannt. Es ist einfach absehbar, die Zahl der Impfstoffe wird noch steigen. Das haben wir ja letztes Mal hier schon durcheteriert, was es da alles ähm so gibt.
Chinesen fangen übrigens auch schon an äh zu impfen mit mit ihren Sinofarmen. Sino, Sino Wax, Sino.
Es kommt ein bisschen durcheinander mit den Namen der Impfstoffe im Namen der äh äh Firmen, aber auf jeden Fall läuft an so und.
Man muss es einfach abwarten, ne? Lässt sich glaube ich an dieser Stelle noch nichts sagen. Von dem Zulassungsverfahren von moderner gibt's auch Neuigkeiten.
Und zwar.
Das ist ja der andere MRNA, basierte Impfstoff in USA entwickelt wurde und ja auch so.
Dann technisch auch dem äh Biontech-Impfstoff eben dann entsprechend nah ist und man hat ja dann auch bei den ersten.
Daten gesehen, dass die auch so im Wesentlichen dieselbe Effizienzrate zu haben scheinen, nämlich von rund fünfundneunzig Prozent, was ein sehr guter Wert ist.
Und die haben jetzt auch äh im Rahmen der Zulassung, des Zulassungsprozesses äh Daten eingereicht, die dann von der FDA auch veröffentlicht wurden.
Es viel Text drin und ein paar bunte Bilder und wenn man mal auf die schaut, sieht man eine ganz interessante Sache, nämlich einerseits, dass die Wirkung da auch nach vierzehn Tagen, nach Verabreichung der ersten Dosis greift,
ähnliche Effizienz gab's auch bei Biontech, also man sieht so richtig hier kommt äh die,
die erste Spritzung und schon zwei Wochen später gibt's
echte Auswirkungen davon, ne? Und das obwohl ja dann vier Wochen später oder drei Wochen später noch eine zweite Dosis gegeben wird,
Aber was ihr jetzt hier auch noch gemacht haben, ist, dass sie bei den Leuten, denen sie die beiden Dosen geimpft haben, jeweils vor der Impfung.
Noch ich vermute mal Blut entnommen haben, also ein Antikörpertest gemacht haben, um zu schauen, ob sozusagen in der jeweiligen Person schon eine Infektion vorlag, die man aber vielleicht nicht bemerkt hat, weil sie,
wie man so schön sagt, asymphomatisch ist. Also das heiß.
Blutprobe entnommen auf Antikörper untersucht, Impfstoff gespritzt, drei oder vier Wochen später dasselbe Spiel nochmal und dann konnten sie quasi
sehen, hat sich irgendjemand zwischen der ersten Impfung und der zweiten Impfung und diesem Drei-Wochen-Fenster,
bereits infiziert, ohne dass es aufgefallen ist. Das ist ja etwas, was bei den ander
nicht gemacht wurde und was die ganze Zeit noch so im Raum stand mit, hilft es auch bei asymptomatischen Fällen, hilft es äh
verhindert es halt unter Umständen auch eine Infektion, das ist ja auch noch so einer äh Frage, die noch im Raum steht, aber jetzt geht's erstmal um die asymptomatischen Fälle und äh stellt sich raus.
Ja, tatsächlich haben sie dabei eine ganze Menge Leute äh erwischt, ne? Das heißt, sie hatten.
Achtunddreißig Leute bei denen das passiert ist in der Kontrollgruppe, also in der Placebo-Gruppe und vierzehn,
in der ähm in der wirklich mit dem richtigen Impfstoff geimpften Gruppe.
Also mit anderen Worten, da man einen direkten Vergleich hat, kann man sagen, okay, zwei Drittel äh der Infektionen wurden schon nach Impf, nach der ersten Impfung äh reduziert und eben auch.
Sichtbar, klar bei diesen asymphomatischen Fällen.
Das ist ähm das ist jetzt also das ist eine gute Zahl, ne? Man hätte jetzt davon ausgehen können, dass weiß ich.
Er sagte, okay, jetzt messen wir auch nochmal vier Wochen nach der zweiten Impfung und gucken mal, was da passiert ist, dass die Zahlen auch weiter äh runtergeht, weil der Körper braucht halt natürlich eine gewisse Zeit, um
diesen Immun, diese Immunreaktion aufzubauen, das sind auf jeden Fall alles relativ gute Zahlen.
Ähm sehe gerade hm moderner.
Hat die EU jetzt von achtzig auf hundertsechzig Millionen Dosen aufgestockt.
Pfeifer Biontech von zweihundert auf dreihundert Millionen. So. Also von daher ist es
vielleicht auch, wenn man, wenn man dann
jetzt auf Politiker eindrischt, warum habt ihr denn jetzt die Option nicht gezogen, als ihr es noch konntet? Es scheint so zu sein, dass sie halt äh ja.
Mit ganz vielen potenziellen Impfstofflieferanten,
Optionen vereinbart haben, aber jetzt als erstes die dort gezogen haben, was verständlich ist von denen, die am weitesten äh sind. Also
Äh und insgesamt sieht's so aus, äh hat die EU jetzt Lieferverträge für eins Komma drei Milliarden Dosen und.
Noch sechshundertsechzig Millionen äh Dosen.
So, was halt bei fünfhundert Millionen äh ja um die fünfhundert Millionen eigentlich.
Mehr als ausreichend sein müsste, um äh die gesamte EU äh durchzuimpfen und dann auch noch äh was weiterzugeben an andere.
So wie es aussieht im Moment. Aber die Frage ist, was halt unklar ist, ist, äh, wann das Ganze kommt, weil.
Schon richtig gesehen hattest äh sind wahrscheinlich du und ich äh in der selben Kategorie wie.
Alle anderen Bundesbürger irgendwie Kategorie, was sechs oder so oder sieben äh mit äh allerletzte Priorität,
und das heißt wahrscheinlich ja,
Irgendwann im Sommer frühestens, äh, wenn man sich das anguckt und ich hab,
auch schon Rechnungen äh gehört oder Zahlen gehört, dass jetzt Entwicklungsländer, die jetzt noch nichts gesichert
haben, beziehungsweise diese Initiative, um auch ärmeren Ländern dem Impfstoff zugänglich zu machen, damit rechnet das manche Entwicklungsländer erst zwanzig vierundzwanzig
Impfstopfe kriegen sollte man sich ein bisschen absurd fand, aber ja äh.
Also bin gespannt wie das läuft mit der Produktion und ob wir auch in Berlin tatsächlich auf die zwanzigtausend kommen.
Werden pro Tag, die da geplant sind. Ja, wobei wir ja mehrere hunderttausend Personen,
haben die wahrscheinlich in Kategorie eins und zwei äh sind. Das hatte ich mir halt auch mal angeguckt in Berlin, äh weil dann die Frage kam, naja, äh.
Wann ähm sagen wir das denn jetzt Auswirkungen zeigen und.
Das wird aber selbst nach jetzigen Planungen ja.
Sag mal, bis Ende Februar könnte man tatsächlich Kategorie eins und zwei durchgeimpft haben, wenn.
Äh die die Zahlen stimmen, insofern könnte es dann tatsächlich auch ab März dann äh Effekte haben, beziehungsweise vielleicht schon auch früher die Zahl der Toten sinken, wenn man.
Die über Achtzigjährigen sehr schnell durchkriegt und die sollen dann ja mit mobilen Teams, die sollen dann vor allem ja.
Ältere Menschen in Heimen äh als erstes äh durchimpfen.
Ja, allerdings Polizei und Feuerwehr und so rangieren ziemlich weit hinten, wenn ich das äh richtig gesehen habe, ne.
Das wird noch so eine offene Debatte sein wer jetzt was in welcher Reihenfolge bekommen.
Ne, ich habe.
Also der Plan ist ja jetzt auch gerade veröffentlicht worden heute, glaube ich, vom äh auf den Bereich mal vorspringen ähm.
Ich habe die Pressekonferenz von dem Sparen mir jetzt nicht komplett äh angeschaut. Also
Gesundheitsminister Spahn hat jetzt erstmal drei Gruppen als erstes genannt. Da sind
für meinen Geschmack relativ wenig Überraschung drin, die jetzt zuerst geimpft werden sollen. Also die erste Gruppe ist sozusagen höchste Priorität
das ist halt einfach medizinisches Personal auf Intensivstationen, in Notaufnahmen, Rettungsdienst äh und Personal im ambulanten Pflegebereich
Klar, ne? Weil das sind immer Leute, da muss schnell gehen und äh geht's halt unter Umständen auch konkret um.
Infizierte äh die müssen halt abgesichert werden. So, zweite Gruppe sind Personen ab siebzig Jahren, demenzkranke Menschen mit Trisomie einundzwanzig
Transplantationspatienten Bewohner von Obdachlosen, Asylbewerberunterkünften und Engelkontaktpersonen von Pflegebedürftigen.
Das ist eine ganz interessante Liste, was sich im Prinzip hier wiederfindet ist, dass man eben versucht, die Leute zu schützen, die am wenigsten in der Lage, sich selbst zu schützen.
Also deswegen auch so demenzkranke, also selbst wenn die im Altersheim sind, denen kannst du halt irgendwie nicht erzählen, setze eine Maske auf, die ist wahrscheinlich zehn Sekunden später liegt die schon wieder irgendwo.
Weil das gar nicht nachvollziehen können oder schon wieder vergessen haben, warum und so weiter und ähm daraus rekrutiert sich eben diese
Liste, Obdachlosen, Asylbewerber, Unterkunft, da finde ich sehr schön, also gerade wo es ohnehin eng zugeht und vielleicht auch mit der Ansprache ein bisschen schwierig ist, also das ist auf jeden Fall,
Gruppe Nummer zwei, dritte Gruppe umfasst über sechzigjährige.
Chronisch kranke Personen in besonders relevanter Position in staatlichen Einrichtungen. Also die Kanzlerin äh sowie Erzieher, Lehrer und Mitarbeiter im Einzelhandel.
Schon eine relativ große Gruppe, so.
Also insgesamt sind's wahrscheinlich in jeder Gruppe äh so nach.
Angaben der ständigen Impfkommission äh so zwischen fünf und zehn Millionen in jener äh Risikogruppe, das heißt.
Kann davon ausgehen eigentlich, dass ja ungefähr,
zwischen ja die Hälfte eigentlich aller Bundesbürger in irgendeine der erhöhten Prioritätsgruppen fällt und die andere Hälfte halt,
danach kommt. So sieht das größenordnungsmäßig aus und.
Also in den ersten drei Gruppen bin ich auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht,
Habe ich aber jetzt auch nicht mit gerechnet. Das passt schon, so. Ähm ja, ich kann nur drauf äh hoffen, dass es relativ schnell geht so oder was weiß ich, wenn äh,
viele Schwobler haben, die ihre Plätze nicht in Anspruch nehmen wollen, dann komme ich auch gerne früher dran, kein Problem.
Ja, also das ist äh sozusagen die Situation jetzt. Da kann man äh glaube ich im Wesentlichen nur abwarten und schauen, was passiert. Ich habe bin da eigentlich relativ zuversichtlich, dass wir das ganz ordentlich organisiert bekommen.
Während in Großbritannien, die sich ja äh extrem dafür gefeiert haben, ja, wie geil sie doch irgendwie diesen Impfstoff äh entwickelt haben und das äh da schon wieder so einen britischen Heroismus äh beschwören mit einem
der in Deutschland von türkisch stämmigen Wissenschaftlern erfunden wurde in USA getestet und produziert wurde. Ja, dass sie damit irgendwie sozusagen ihren Nationalismus anfeuern, das versteht wahrscheinlich auch wirklich nur äh
die konservative Partei und die vielleicht auch schon nicht mehr. Hier äh wenn man einfach mal,
gucken, ich denke, das Interesse ist einfach klar und äh das wird jetzt einfach Fahrt aufnehmen.
Ja gucken wir doch mal kurz auf die Kosten. Was hat denn das eigentlich alles gekostet? Ich habe da irgendwie eine äh Übersicht gesehen,
ähm die mal so ein bisschen angeschaut hat, was was wurde da eigentlich alles eingesetzt.
Ähm die das äh Bericht der BBC ähm.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt die Zahlen nur in Pfund,
Das Pfund ist gerade etwas äh volatil und ich weiß zu faul, das irgendwie umzurechnen, aber ich glaube, das Punt ist äh mittlerweile so weit runter, dass man jetzt hier auch äh das einfach Euro nennen kann. Also die Entwicklungskosten,
bei dem Ochsford im Stoff eins Komma sechs fünf ähm Milliarden Pfund ähm.
Dann ist nennt man die, die wir jetzt hier schon so oft besprochen haben, moderner, fünfhundertdreiundneunzig äh Millionen.
Milliarden äh Millionen Jahren. Mhm. Nee, ja nicht Milliarden.
Ja oder eben habe ich Milliarden gesagt, also eins Komma sechs Milliarden. Jetzt sind wir quasi bei null Komma fünf neun Milliarden und äh Pfeiser, Biontech null Komma vier Milliarden. Also die MRNA-Stoffe waren gar nicht mal so teuer, interessanterweise.
Äh die anderen liegen irgendwo dazwischen, also von von Quawak, die haben irgendwie mittlerweile achthundertfünfzig,
Millionen reingeschmissen, Johnson und Johnson, der noch äh im Test ist und auch Nova wachsen. Noch im Test liegen halt auch so sechshundert bis eins Komma.
Milliarden, also das sind so die äh die Zahlen, die hier so aufgerufen wurden, da ist schon eine Menge Holz, ne? Ist schon klar, warum Unternehmen normalerweise solche.
Entwicklung halt nur machen, wenn sie wirklich wissen, dass es ihnen abgenommen wird. Und das ist halt in der Regel nicht der Fall.
Was aber jetzt hier interessant ist, ist, wo kommt dieses Geld her und tatsächlich ist der Großteil,
dieser Investitionen Government Funding, also bei,
Ochsford ist es irgendwie über die Hälfte bei Curvac ist es fast drei Viertel bei moderner ist es fast vollständig die Finanzierung.
Und auch bei Bion Take sind äh zwei Drittel der Finanzierung Government Funding.
Und der Rest kommt so aus äh privaten äh Schatullen. Das ist äh sozusagen ähm,
ja, weiß ich nicht ganz genau wissen, wissen, wo du das ist. Beim Ochsford gibt's auch noch so Notform Profit, die noch einen relativ großen Teil gut vierzig Prozent übernommen haben.
Das ist sozusagen das, wo die Kohle herkommt. Also im Wesentlichen ist es das, was die Impfstoffentwicklung ermöglicht hat, das sozusagen das Geld. Genau. Ja und jetzt die Preise.
Mhm. Da.
Auch bekannt geworden.
Mhm. Durch einen Leak von der Verbraucherschutzstaatssekretärin.
Blicker in Belgien. Die hat halt da am Donnerstag.
Gestern ja am Donnerstag eine Tabelle mit Preisen pro Dosis der,
sechs Unternehmen getwittert und wieder gelöscht, aber natürlich ja hat das schon jemand gescreen schottet und äh ja,
demnach ist der moderne Impfstoff wohl am teuersten mit achtzehn Dollar pro Basis, äh Prodosis.
Johnson und Johnson und wie acht fünfzig.
Dollar, Biontech, Fisa, zwölf Euro, die ist mein Euro.
Ähm zehn Euro.
Und irgendwie Sanofi sieben sechsundfünfzig und Astra Sinnika hat mir den eigentlich, den hatten wir gar nicht mit drin. Äh.
Wahrscheinlich.
Eins acht eins achtundsiebzig pro Dosis. Das war, glaube ich, der Klasse einer von den klassischen Impfstoffen, Richt.
Also in
in den ähm in dem BBC-Artikel sind auch Zahlen, die liegen jetzt, würde ich sagen, ungefähr zwanzig bis dreißig Prozent über dem, was du gesagt hast, aber in dem gleichen Verhältnis
Das sind also auch so Schätz äh Werte. Das mag natürlich sein, dass das jetzt sozusagen der effektive Preis ist, den die EU da ausgehandelt hat.
Weil seine Ziele nicht so, dass da jetzt irgendwie auf die Webseite gehst und eine Preisliste runterladen kannst, sondern so so in dem Bereich bewegt sich das. Ja gut, ich meine, das,
deckt sich so ein bisschen mit dem, was man eigentlich auch schon vorher wusste, ne? Also diese MRNA äh Impfstoffe sind noch relativ teuer, das ist ja auch alles äh moderne Technik, da kommt diese ganze Kühlerei und was weiß ich was, nicht noch alles dazu. Also da,
Aber man muss ja auch dazu sagen, sie sind ja auch wirklich extrem effizient. Also es ist sozusagen auch ihr Geld äh.
Sie kosten einen Bruchteil äh von einem PCA-Test, muss man auch dazu sagen, ja.
Ist, das ist richtig.
Also.
Billiger zu impfen als einmal zu testen.
Und der Oxford äh Impfstoff, das war eh schon klar, dass der günstig wird, weil äh einfach für diese Art von dem Stoff,
extrem viel Produktionsstätten
bereits existieren. Da muss gar nicht viel Neues zu aufgebaut werden. Moderner und Fiser, das ist sozusagen, also diese MR-Geschichte, das befindet sich alles noch im Aufbau und da werden die Kapazitäten erst hochgezogen, dementsprechend muss da mehr reininvestiert werden, dementsprechend ist natürlich dann auch
die äh der Preis pro Dosis höher während halt äh wenn der äh Ochsford im Show freigegeben ist, halt in Indien größere Pharmabatterien bereitstehen, um den halt irgendwie in
riesigen Mengen rauszupumpen. Ja. Alles in allem nicht sonderlich überraschend. Es gibt eine gewisse Preisspanne
am Ende sind es aber alles so Preise die man durchaus bezahlen
kann, insbesondere können sich, glaube ich, die Industrieländer, die teureren Impfstoffe sehr wohl leisten und wenn äh der Oxford-Impfstoff wirklich gut funktioniert und dann auch einen entsprechenden Mengen zugelassen
wird dann kann man auch den Rest der Welt damit wunderbar helfen.
Welches ist denn jetzt der Billgets-Impfstoff, der.
Es gibt nicht in dem Sinne den Bill Gates im Stoff, sondern Bill Gates hat glaube ich äh in den Aufbau von Produktionskapazitäten in verschiedenen äh.
Projekten Geld reingeworfen. Genaue Liste kann ich dir jetzt gerade nicht sagen.
Es war, glaube ich, in dem Artikel, den man letzte Woche verlinkt hat, war das, glaube ich, äh am Rande erwähnt. Kriegst aber jetzt äh nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Gut.
Das zu den Kosten. Ähm, dann habe ich nochmal so ein bisschen geschaut, äh es gibt jetzt äh eine neue Art von Webseite, die jetzt gerade hip ist und zwar die Chrona Virus Wexin Tracker.
Jetzt, wo das eben äh losgeht mit den Impfstoffen, gibt's äh verschiedene Webseiten, die sich jetzt der Frage äh genähert haben mit äh okay, was ähm,
was passiert denn jetzt sozusagen? Wie sind denn diese Fortschritte? Und ich sage mal gleich vorweg so einen richtigen Favoriten habe ich nicht. Ich habe äh die, die ich jetzt hier erwähne, sind alle verlinkt, könnt ihr euch selber mal anschauen. Ich fange mal an hier mit dem ähm.
Kovet neunzehn wächsen Tracker der McGill University, die ist aus Kanada, Montrial
die hat irgendwie eine ganz gute Übersicht, insbesondere auch
über diese verschiedenen Typen. Da haben wir ja auch schon einiges drüber gesprochen. Es gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche Typen und um da so ein bisschen Überblick zu bekommen, haben die das hier äh farblich schön gemacht. Also das ist sozusagen eine Quelle, die euch mal anschauen
könnt. Neunzehn Punkt Track wegseens, dot org Slash Wexins. Ähm ein bisschen nördiger, ein Projekt aus Indien hat das, glaube ich, zusammengebaut. Tracker dot com
da sind auch die Zeitphasen sehr viel besser zu sehen.
Ähm, also wo befindet sich sozusagen ein Impfstoff gerade in welcher Phase und wie weit sind die da vorangekommen? Ähm so ein bisschen so Zahlen nördiger
Und dann gibt's noch einen Tracker von Blumenberg auf Blumenberg äh dot com. Der ist äh,
schön übersichtlich,
weil er so Timelines äh aufmacht, das heißt, da kann man dann schön ähm bei den populäreren,
Impfstoffen, also die, die jetzt mehr,
In der Diskussion sind, schnell sehen, ah okay, wann haben die denn mal angefangen? Wann haben die Trial angefangen, wann äh gab's die Resultate, wann gab's die Eprovels und so weiter und der ganze Rollout, also da kriegt man da einen ganz guten
Überblick und dann gibt's noch einen.
Ach so und Blumenburg hat auch eine ganz gute Übersicht über die Verteilung der Impfstoffe, also wer äh kriegt was, ja? Also welcher Impfstoff geht äh wohin? Das ist dann so ein bisschen so eine Grafik wie.
Wählerwanderung, ja? Kennst du,
dieses so von links nach rechts äh von Impfstoff zu Land und da kann man dann halt auch nochmal sehen, aha hier EU als Empfänger bezieht halt so nach,
dem aktuellen Stand, den ich da gescreen schottet habe, mag sich schon wieder geändert haben. Also kriegt aus, kriegt von Oxford um die dreihundert Millionen Downs, Dosen, dreihundert von Sanovi, zweihundertfünfundzwanzig.
Und so, ich komme hier auf die Summe von eins Komma drei Millionen Dosierungen, das ist das, was du äh Milliarden wahrscheinlich meinen Sinn, ne?
Das haben sie ja falsch beschrieben, genau
Komma drei Milliarden äh Dosen, also das, was du vorhin gesagt hast und äh hier kann man halt schnell sehen, okay, welcher Impfstoff geht wohin, ne? Wer geht in die Welt, wer geht sonst wohin? Wo gehen die chinesischen Impfstoffe hin und so. Das könnte nochmal ganz,
interessant werden und als letzter der Cover neunzehn wird sie ein Tracker dot org vom Milkeninstitut. Das ist aus Kalifornien.
Und äh der ist ein bisschen fancy,
gemacht und es ist so so eine Hippe Scrollseite, die sich permanent ändert, wenn man von oben nach unten durchscrollt, also dass die schon so ah, müsst ihr das alles so
verspielt machen, aber tatsächlich fand ich die sehr
schön weil sie dann unten dann wirklich 'ne sehr erklärbarmäßige.
Ähm Aufstellung hart von allen und zu jedem Impfstoff äh extrem viele Details zusammengetragen hat. Also
Er hat das Projekt losgetreten. Was sind da die nächsten Schritte und so weiter? Listet alle Clinical Trials aus mit,
entsprechenden Nummern äh et cetera in allen Kategorien. Also da kann man sich sozusagen so richtig äh satt klicken.
Das ist sozusagen das, was äh jetzt gerade,
aufkommen, da mag's noch ein paar andere geben, aber wie gesagt, fünf Stück habe ich euch schon mal zusammengesucht, könnt ihr euch mal selber was raussuchen, was euch gefällt.
Ich bin da gerade hängengeblieben ähm.
An äh ja dieser Weltkarte wo drauf zu sehen ist, wie viel Prozent denn äh der Bevölkerung jetzt gecovert sind.
Mit äh ja Verträgen für Impfstoffe.
Den Blumenberg Trecker.
In Blumenberg Tracker.
Und das ist krass. Am meisten hat Kanada vorgesorgt. Das hat irgendwie fünfhundertelf Prozent der Bevölkerung Covert, also fünfmal so viele äh äh.
Impfstoffe, wie sie wirklich brauchen. EU hat so eine Coverage von hundertzweiundsiebzig Prozent, also EU-weit, bisschen mehr als die Amerikaner, die haben hundertvierundfünfzig Prozent Coverage.
UK ist mit zweihundertfünfundneunzig Prozent, also es ist schon aus der EU irgendwie ausgeschert äh bei der Geschichte äh so.
Da setzen sie vor allem auf ihren eigenen Stoff da aus Ochsford.
Australien zweihundertdreißig Prozent und ja Japan hundertzwanzig Prozent bunt.
Interessanterweise USP-Kistan gehört noch zu den Ländern, die über hundert Prozent liegen.
Und Chile und äh ja äh Mexiko interessanterweise auch.
Und einer ist noch vergessen.
Neuseeland natürlich.
Genau und Neuseeland hat auch äh angekündigt, dass sie nicht nur sich selber durchimpfen, sondern dass sie auch äh quasi den ganzen pazifischen Raum auch noch mit abdecken äh Australien übrigens auch. Also auch die ganzen,
die ganzen Inseln hier, Tuwalo, Trallala, alles der ganze pazifische Raum um Neuseeland herum wird quasi von Neuseeland mitversorgt.
Okay, deswegen sind die beide sie haben zweihundertsiebenundvierzig Prozent äh in dem.
Ansonsten ja alle anderen Länder.
Die wir jetzt nicht genannt haben, haben äh noch nicht genug Lieferverträge, um ihre äh gesamte äh,
äh Population zu impfen bisher, zumindest laut dieser Karte. Russland ist bei fünfundfünfzig Prozent
ja, Iran, fünf Prozent, Saudi-Arabien, fünf Prozent, also die meisten afrikanischen Länder scheinen irgendwie.
Im Moment bei fünf Prozent zu liegen. Einzelne bei zehn Prozent und nur Ägypten sticht raus mit einundsechzig Prozent.
Ja, Brasilien vierundsechzig. Also, ich denke mal, dass eine Momentaufnahme,
dürfte sich wahrscheinlich relativ schnell ändern, aber es ist schon relativ ersichtlich, dass hier bestimmte Länder in der EU äh einfach die Nase vorn haben, gar keine Frage.
Also man kann ganz klar sagen, dass so aussieht, dass sich hier offensichtlich der Westen erstmal die ganzen Impfstoffe unter Nagel äh reißt äh.
Die gut wahrscheinlich auch in all den Ländern entwickelt und produziert werden.
Ja gut, ich meine Indien kauft auch ordentlich ein, aber die haben halt auch wirklich viele Leute, ne? Also das ist sozusagen,
Das muss auch alles erstmal abgedeckt werden. Das Gleiche gilt auch für für China. Andererseits äh haben die Länder teilweise auch ihre Ausbrüche besser im äh Griff.
Ja, dann,
gibt's auch noch von meiner Lieblingsstatistik Webseite Hour World Indata gibt's auch eine neue Sektion, die sich eben diesen Impfung
zuwendet. Hier gibt es jetzt quasi eine Auflistung mit welche Länder haben denn jetzt schon wie viel geimpft.
Ja, also da äh entwickelt sich jetzt in der nächsten Zeit mal eine Übersicht
wie viele Dosierungen wurden denn tatsächlich äh verabreicht, ja? Das ist hier mit Pure One Hundred äh People aufgelistet und derzeit an der Spitze der Entwicklung liegt.
Schottland, die sozusagen null Komma drei drei äh von,
hundert, also null Komma drei drei Prozent der Bevölkerung durchgeimpft haben. Es geht voran.
Gefolgt von Wales, lustigerweise teilen sie das hier sogar schon äh nach den einzelnen Königreichen äh des Vereinigten Königreichs auf, was ihr
hier schon die Trennung voraussehen oder ob die einfach nur mehr Übersicht schaffen wollen? Na ja.
Ja, in der Blumenbergtabelle sehe ich, ist aber auch England, Schottland, Wales und Nordirland unterteilt.
Ja. Äh an welcher Stelle.
Ähm da gibt's so eine Tabelle in der im obersten Drittel äh.
Okay, gut. Max Sinn machen oder äh nicht.
Nach absoluten, also da sind absolute Zahlen halt aufgelistet und ja danach hatte China allerdings ja sind da die Zahlen alt für China.
Die sechshundertfünfzigtausend Leute am achtundzwanzigsten November na ja.
Gut, so viel zu den Treckern. Dann wurde ich noch auf eine ähm.
Auf ein Szenario hingewiesen, was auf Twitter von dem.
Twitter-Account äh bissiges Mäuschen äh.
Verbreitet wurde, das scheint mir eine Person aus dem Gesundheitssystem zu sein. Äh folge ich noch nicht so lange, deswegen orientiere ich mich da noch, aber da gab's dann irgendwie einen längeren Shret, der sich jetzt sozusagen.
Mit möglichen Szenarien bezüglich, wie sich denn das jetzt äh in der Gesellschaft bei uns so verhält mit äh äh Auswirkungen der Impfung.
Auf die gesellschaftliche Debatte, insbesondere ähm unter Berücksichtigung der Schwubler Beeinflussung
Ja, also was was könnten jetzt sozusagen alles wieder für interessante Informationsverdrehungen vorgenommen werden und neue Verschwörungstheorien aufgelegt werden
im Rahmen der nächsten Monate, die davon geprägt sein werden, dass wir eben diesen Impfprozess äh hochfahren. Und ähm
stellt dann in diesem Schritt erstmal fest, so ja okay, also jetzt geht's natürlich erstmal los mit Risikogruppen, medizinisches Personal, die werden jetzt zuerst äh geimpft
kann natürlich Tote äh verhindern und es kann vor allem auch Krankenhäuser entlasten. Einerseits dadurch, dass es halt weniger schwere Fälle gibt und dass es weniger,
etwas Personal gibt natürlich, das ne am Ende vielleicht einfach weniger zu tun gibt und mehr Leute dafür auch tatsächlich zur Verfügung stehen, das zu tun, was getan werden muss
Ähm allerdings in dieser ersten Phase, wo das jetzt so durchgesetzt wird. Ähm.
Ist auch klar, dass das auf die Virusverbreitung relativ geringen Einfluss hat. Weil diese Gruppen nicht unbedingt jetzt die Potenziellen Supersprayer sind, ne? Also die alten Heime stehen so
am Ende der Versorgung. Die äh müssen zwar den, die haben den Schaden, aber die sind ja nicht die Ursache, dementsprechend
wird also selbst, wenn jetzt diese ganzen Risikogruppen beimpft werden, äh haben wir die Chance auf weniger Tote.
Aber ähm es wird nicht dazu führen, dass weniger Virusverbreitung stattfindet. Und ähm.
Es könnte dann doch das Problem auftreten, dass geimpfte trotzdem auch noch krank werden und sterben.
Weil das halt einfach bei Älteren so ist.
Ja selbst wenn sie geimpft sind kann es halt einfach sein, ich meine wir haben einerseits diese diese fünf Prozent ja die,
sozusagen keine Wirkung äh zeigt und natürlich immer noch den Faktor, dass so dann eben bei älteren Leuten auch einfach äh Leute hast, die einfach auch so sterben,
Also ja, das ist dann so diese Debatte mit irgendwie äh mit Kovitch sterben oder Ankovit sterben, ja.
Nur das zu erwarten ist genau, dass die äh Schwabler oder wie auch immer man sie nennt. Ich würde äh.
Sagen. Ja, ja, heftigere Worte äh dafür benutzen, aber dass sie's genau umdrehen so sagen nach dem Motto okay, bislang sind die Toten ja alle.
Sagen.
Mit und nicht an äh Kovit äh gestorben und in Zukunft werden sie dann aber alle Ankowitt gestorben äh äh sein äh und das äh weil der Impfstoff nicht wirkt. Ja.
Erinnert mich so an das, was gerade in den USA abgeht.
Mit sagen der sag mal den den Wahlsystemkritikern oder äh Wahlsystem Skeptikern sage ich mal oder Wahlausgangsskeptikern und zwar äh.
Haben gestern verschiedene Abgeordnete und Senatoren dann berichtet, wie sie denn dann zu Hause bei den Wählern waren und die Wähler,
alle,
sagen Skepsis äh hinsichtlich des Wahlausgangs geäußert haben und große Sorgen haben, was die Integrität des Wahlsystems angeht, ja? Äh so dass es halt,
wie so eine Mentalität nach dem Motto erst, ja äh.
Sagen das verbreiten äh so und dann ankommen und das Ganze komplett auf den Kopf drehen. So ähm diese Leute überhaupt gar keine Probleme mit.
Ja, also sie berichten sozusagen von der Verunsicherung, die sie selber vorher.
Genau. Mhm.
Genau, das ist natürlich genauso dieser äh Punkt, ne? So oder so werden wir natürlich jetzt, das wird in diesem Tritt auch nochmal erwähnt an so einen Punkt kommen, wo
die wo so eine Überschätzung der Erfolge dann natürlich auch dazu führen kann, dass die Leute wieder ihre Vorsichtigkeit ausschalten, so nach dem Motto, na ja, jetzt kommt ja der Impfstoff, jetzt sind ja schon so viele geimpft, jetzt kann ja nicht mehr so sehr viel passieren und da sind eben genau
äh äh das passiert.
Ich würde es eher umgekehrt sehen, man will sich sagen mal auf den letzten Metern eigentlich nicht mehr anstecken, wobei das natürlich für viele die letzten Meter irgendwie Sommer bedeutet, aber ja.
Umso umso wichtiger ist es aber auch, weil.
Die Hälfte von uns bis zum Sommer wohl nicht in den Genuss eines Impfstoffs äh kommen wird ähm dass wir bis dahin halt die Zahlen sinken und unten halten, weil.
Ja was nicht geht, ist das die Hälfte der Leute irgendwie dann äh weiter bis zum Sommer im Lokdown äh.
Ja, nee, also das geht natürlich überhaupt nicht. Genau.
Ja dann schreibt er oder sie noch von ähm einem Art Note Sibo bei Proxie-Effekt, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt nur so begrenzt äh verstanden, ist ja nur Cebo Effekt ist ja sozusagen so ein.
Aspektes ähm.
Ja, ist das Gegenteil.
Cebo Effekt, so nach dem Motto, wenn du halt äh auf der Zigarettenschachtel jetzt diese ganzen Bilder von Krankheiten hast, dass dadurch dann die Leute krank werden, weil sie glauben äh,
Rauchen schädlicher ist dadurch und ja es dann wirklich schädlicher wird.
So nach dem Motto man guckt halt jetzt äh auf die man beobachtet, die Geimpften und stellt dann sozusagen auf einmal.
Irgendwelche Symptome fest, die dann als Wirkung gedeutet werden der Impfung sozusagen, dass der den Impfstoff dann unterstellt wird hier, das kann ja das und das machen, ne? Ja.
Mhm.
Genau, die Nummer, ja genau. Ja. Ja und und ganz andere neue Sach.
Und keine Ahnung, ja und rote Haare, also das, das sind auf jeden Fall interessante Überlegungen, ich verlinke mal diesen äh,
Fred und will damit aber jetzt erstmal gar nichts implizieren. Ich glaube, ich bin da eigentlich relativ.
Aber ich bin ja immer relativ optimistisch, von daher ist es eigentlich auch sinnlos, das zu erwähn.
Gut, kommen wir äh so langsam zum äh Ende. Da können wir nochmal ganz kurz in die Welt der Corona Warn-App beziehungsweise dieser Exposa-Notification,
äh vorstoßen. Da es ja nicht unbedingt alles jetzt unbedingt so gelaufen wie,
man das vielleicht sich hätte erhoffen äh können. Die App hat sicherlich so eine bestimmte Wirkung gehabt, aber es hat sich halt gezeigt bei der Verbreitung, die es gefunden hat, kann es eben nicht alle Probleme alleine lösen
Abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich immer wieder Probleme gegeben hat. Es sind noch ein paar andere Sachen passiert. Also zunächst einmal
kurz zurückspulen, dieses Exposia-Notification Frambok, also das ist quasi so die Basis.
Dessen, mit dem diese Corona-Warn-App und die anderen Apps in Europa,
arbeiten, ne? Lädt sich die App runter und die werden dann gestartet auf dem Telefon und sagen, hallo, ich bin's, deine Corona Warneb. Ich möchte jetzt hier ganz gerne mit diesen Subsystemen,
Telefons reden, was mir diesen ganzen Bluetoothaustausch ermöglicht und das ist halt ein Teil des Betriebssystems.
Und vor einer Weile,
das hatten wir hier glaube ich auch erwähnt, bin mal gar nicht ganz so sicher gab's ja so eine Neuerung
dass äh Apple und Google gesagt haben, so jetzt gibt's halt hier das sogenannte Exposa Notification Express,
Und das bedeutet, dass wenn eine Land diesen ganzen Aufwand mit dieser App nicht treiben will,
dass im Prinzip alles äh an Bordmitteln da ist, um das auch ohne extra installierte App zu machen,
Alles, was man tun muss, ist dieses Backend aufzusetzen und da gab's dann halt einen entsprechenden Server von Google, das heißt, du kannst ja bei Google Open Source diesen Exposar Notification-Server
installieren dem Betreiben bei Apple und Google anmelden und sagen hier, hör mal, ich bin's Dollar Land. Äh ich habe jetzt hier diesen Server, äh aktiviert doch mal bitte auf dem Telefon, die Funktion für diesen Bereich so
dass er damit redet, das heißt, du brauchst nicht erst so eine App.
Einschalten, sondern es reicht, wenn du quasi auf dem Telefon auf dem nackten Betriebssystem sagst, hier mach mal und dann brauchst halt nur noch den Server gehen,
Das ist jetzt wohl in Kalifornien an Start gegangen. Das finde ich wirklich vollkommen vollkommen.
Es macht mich ein bisschen fassungslos, also da hätte ich jetzt auch Geld drauf gewettet, dass es auf gar keinen Fall so läuft. Also gerade in Kalifornien bin ich davon ausgegangen, die fangen halt einfach an. Die sind die ersten mit der App und dann geht's los. So
hat alles nicht stattgefunden, jetzt nehmen sie daran teil. Das ist jetzt nicht explizit nochmal auf so eine App setzen.
Gut geschenkt, also ich denke gibt einiges, was dafür spricht, solche so eine App anzubieten, aber äh so ist vielleicht auch ganz gut.
Ja
dann hat Apple auch äh was Überraschendes getan und zwar haben sie ein Betriebssystem Update rausgebracht, das iOS zwölf Punkt fünf.
Aktuell aktuelle Telefone haben gerade so Version vierzehn Punkt drei SP Speak,
Das bedeutet, dass es ein Update für Telefone, die eben dieses iOS dreizehn und vierzehn nicht fahren können und das betrifft eben auch die viel diskutierten iPhone fünf S und sechs Modelle,
Das war ja so eine Debatte immer mit Bugott, Apple lässt ja so viele alte Telefone raus und ne, wie kann die Corona Warnapp äh denn funktionieren, wenn sie nicht überall läuft
Ähm iPhones scheinen ja ohnehin überdurchschnittlich viel, diese Chorona-Warn-App äh zu haben. Also mehr,
Leute, die ein iPhone haben, laden die App runter und betreiben die als Leute, die ein Anruftelefon haben.
Der konkrete äh,
Anteil der Instaltbase die seit alten Telefone, die er teilweise sieben Jahre alt sind. Ähm.
Ist mir nicht klar. Also es gibt verschiedene Statistiken, die.
Teilweise sich aber auch nur die Verbreitung von Betriebssystemen auf den letzten vier Jahren anschauen. Also wie viele von diesen Telefonen tatsächlich in Betrieb sind
Weiß ich nicht. Ich denke mal, es kann sich eigentlich nur um wenige Prozent handeln. Trotz alledem gibt's halt jetzt nochmal ein Update für diese alten Telefone und da ist dann dieses Exposion Ludification auch mit dabei
Das bedeutet, dass diese Chronawarn-App nachgerüstet werden muss. Ähm.
Um sozusagen auch auf dem alten Betriebssystem zu laufen, weil bisher hieß es ja immer
dreizehn und äh aufwärts und jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie viel Tricks sie quasi da äh in ihrer App drin haben, die einfach davon ausgehen, dass ein bis dreizehn da ist, also,
könnte eine größere Änderung bedeuten, muss es nicht unbedingt, könnte aber sein.
Und ähm ich vermute immer mal, dass äh Testes kommt.
Ja, Updates sind ohnehin noch einige geplant. Einerseits gibt's jetzt gerade eine neue Version. Corona war eines Punkt neun
da ist dann halt auch diese neue Version von diesem Framework berücksichtigt, haben wir ja glaube ich auch schon mal kurz angesprochen. Das ist jetzt so eine neue Risikobewertungsmethode
äh gibt, das funktioniert also jetzt sozusagen alles ein bisschen anders, man hat das mal überarbeitet und die neue Version ähm,
Das konnte ich aber jetzt äh aus verständlichen Gründen nicht ähm nachvollziehen. Wenn man jetzt gewarnt wird, dann gibt's wohl jetzt genauere Informationen darüber, wie lange das her ist, äh auf welches Datum sich das
zieht et cetera. Das war ja sozusagen so ein so ein Kritikpunkt, den wir hier glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal,
dass das einfach ein bisschen unklar ist und man einfach nicht so richtig weiß, wie man das äh deuten soll und das bezieht sich glaube ich jetzt auch auf diese niedrigen Risiken,
das muss man auch mal schauen. Ja.
Ja und geplant ist wohl, das äh hat der Spahn äh fallen lassen, dass äh man auch noch Funktionen nachrüstet äh bezüglich der Impfung, sodass man eben die Chrona-Barnep auch noch benutzen kann, um sozusagen Impf,
also um Symptome zurückzumelden. Ähm, nach einer Impfung aus auch noch ganz sinnvoll sein kann.
Das klingt vernünftig, ja? Ja, generell ich meine, weil die Diskussion ja jetzt auch immer wieder,
aufkommt ähm so, was hat die denn jetzt gebracht und was bringt die, denn die Corona Warneb ist das nicht einfach nur ein teures Spielzeug und rausgeschmissen Geld.
So und.
Die Frage ist ja auch immer Anfang diskutiert worden, äh wie viel kann denn so eine Corona Warnapp äh eigentlich leisten und bringen und,
meine das hängt natürlich von ganz vielen Faktoren ab, als allererstes natürlich die Verbreitung. Wir wie sehen die Downloadzahlen jetzt aus, also zuletz,
weil sich zweiundzwanzig Millionen oder so war die letzte Zahl, die ich gehört hatte.
Ja, in der Größenordnung.
Aber irgendwo in der Gegend und.
Dreiundzwanzig acht sind die aktuellen Downloadzahlen, was aber nichts darüber sagt, wie viel halt wirklich.
Und irgendwie, ich glaube achtzig Prozent oder so nutzen, die ich glaube, das waren so das Verhältnis irgendwie Downloadzahl zu, äh wie viele.
Die Benutzer. Es gibt Sammelgrößen aus unsmäßig zwanzig Millionen jetzt, das ist natürlich noch ein bisschen wenig. Das ist schon ein bisschen was.
Aber man weiß halt, okay, wenn ich sage mal wenigstens so etwas über die Hälfte der Leute, äh die benutzen würden.
Dann gab's so Modelle, die so ich glaube fünf bis zehn Prozent oder so.
Reduktion in Aussicht gestellt hatten. Ich würde das jedenfalls für eine realistische Größenordnung halten, dass so eine App.
Wenn sie denn jetzt ja von der Mehrheit benutzt wird irgendwo in der Größenordnung von fünf Prozent bringt ungefähr so viel wie.
Ja, Ausgangsbeschränkungen oder so. Also es ist nicht viel, ja, alleine mit der Corona Warn.
Kann man sicherlich das nicht.
Äh alleine bekämpfen so, aber äh so sie leistet einen Beitrag und wie viel? Also ich würde mal denken vielleicht.
Einen Prozent oder so, zwei Prozent am am Runde in der Gegend aber
selbst wenn sage mal ein Toter dadurch verhindert wird und das halte ich für sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich, dass äh durch die Corona Warnapp mehrere Todesfälle und
sicherlich auch zig oder hunderte von Infektionen verhindert wurden. Das ist natürlich im Gesamtkontext
nicht viel, aber äh so ähm es kostet.
Praktisch nichts im Vergleich zu äh was die sonstigen Kosten sind und äh ja.
Ich denke, es hilft äh mehr als dass es äh schadet und äh insofern bin ich nach wie vor der Meinung, das ist eine gute Sache.
Aber damit.
Der Effekt auch noch stärker wird, ist nicht nur mehr Nutzung nötig, wozu natürlich mehr Features und Informationen und so beitragen können, sondern die.
Zweite Sache ist, äh dass die ganze Meldekette auch schnell funktioniert. Das ist ja der eigentliche Vorteil der App, dass wenn die,
Labore äh dann sagen direkt,
zeitnah die Information übermitteln und dass das dann halt schnell rausgeht und die Geschwindigkeit ist halt auch noch ganz äh wichtig, damit man dann vor die Ausbreitung äh kommt und die Ausbreitung stoppt,
bevor sie allzu viele Leute erreicht hat und da muss man sagen, ich weiß nicht wie viel Labore inzwischen angebunden sind, aber ich habe
mehrfach auch gehört, dass äh der Arzt angerufen hat und dann zwei Tage später kam dann die
Warnung von der äh
oder die die Mitteilung über die Corona App so ungefähr und das ist natürlich nicht wie es gedacht ist, sondern es soll natürlich umgekehrt sein das halt. Im Prinzip
unverzüglich, sobald der Test aus der Maschine fällt, äh, eigentlich.
Die Benachrichtigung äh automatisch äh ja rausgegeben werden sollte, so da zählt dann jede Stunde.
Klar, also ich meine, der Teufel steckt natürlich äh wieder im Detail. Ich habe unzählige Berichte gehört, mit wo es gut funktioniert hat und wo es nicht so gut funktioniert hat.
Von kam sehr, sehr, sehr schnell und hat alles so funktioniert, wie es auf der Box steht, bis hin zu
Berichten so aus dem Maschinenraum, so, na ja, es scheitert teilweise daran, dass dass
das Feld äh auf dem Datenschutz Zettel, den man noch äh an abhaken muss, dass äh wie das Feld nicht richtig angekreuzt war und das dann sozusagen der Scanner,
der das so übernimmt und äh die die Bestätigung einsammelt, diese dann nicht nicht nicht sieht oder nicht nicht korrekt interpretiert und dass es dann daran hängt, es gab Probleme in der App,
wenn man jetzt schon seinen zweiten Test hat, dass dann da der Alte irgendwie nicht gelöscht wurde und der dann keinen neuen Empfang konnte. Also da sind sozusagen in diesem gesamten Prozess, wie das eigentlich auch vollkommen normal ist bei so Softwareentwicklung.
Siehst, aha okay. Wie verhält sich denn jetzt eigentlich meine App, wenn sie in der in der Realität mit echten Laboren, mit echten Verpeilungen, Fehlern,
meinetwegen auch Coding Bucks und so weiter. Zurecht kommt, dann dann siehst du eben bestimmte Dinge überhaupt erst, beziehungsweise kannst bestimmte Fälle, die man an die man vorher einfach,
gar nicht so gedacht hat, ja? Oder die sich durch später erlassene Regeln überhaupt erst gezeigt haben, dann musst du halt nachrüst,
So, das wird jetzt immerhin getan. Es gibt eine kontinuierliche Weiterentwicklung, das finde ich gut
so, also das war meine große Befürchtung, dass das nicht gemacht wird. Ich hoffe, dass das Ding bald mal so ein ordentliches Dashboard bekommt, weil das könnte wirklich, wirklich, wirklich für viele Leute interessant sein. Es ist
immer noch extrem schwierig, wenn du dich jetzt einfach mal über die aktuelle Zahlensituation informieren möchtest.
Wo guckst du denn da? Da hast du tausend Webseiten auf irgendwelchen äh Homepages von Verlagen, von Tageszeitungen und so weiter mit unheimlich viel äh Web zwei null, Bremborium und Pipapo, aber einfach mal nur so,
App öffnen, zack, wie die Zahlen, wie sieht's,
mir in der Gemeinde aus, wie sieht's bei mir im Landkreis aus? Wie sieht's bei mir im Bundesland aus? Wie sitzen Deutschland an sich aus? Dass man das einfach mit einem Blick,
sehen kann. Das ist so ein No-Brainer und sowas gibt's halt nicht und das ist irgendwie,
so, aber wenn das kommt, wiederum könnte das eben die Akzeptanz erhöhen, weil einfach die App an verschiedenen Stellen hilft. So und das ist, glaube ich, das, wie man vielleicht diese App auch mehr sehen sollte. Ich finde den Namen ja nach wie vor so ein bisschen,
schlecht so, ähm ich hätte ja eher so den den Corona äh,
Company gesehen, ja, der so ein bisschen so dein Freund ist und nicht immer so mit diesem bösen Warnung, Gefahr,
daher kommt so so dein Corona-Kompenien für harte Zeiten irgendwie.
Ich hätt's auch sehr interessant gefunden, aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht kommen. Äh wenn er einfach auch im Dashboard überhaupt zu sehen wäre, wie viele,
verschiedene eigentlich mein Telefon so gesehen hat, ja? So wie viel ja.
Wie viel Aktivität das ist, das gibt ja wiederum das Framework nicht frei,
Also das ist sozusagen derzeit gar nicht zu generieren. Aber wie gesagt, einfach benutzbar sein, täglichen Wert haben, äh das tägliche Interesse ähm bedienen, damit ist schon eine ganze Menge geholfen äh,
Allein schon mal, was sind denn eigentlich gerade die Regeln? Ja, ich wohne in Berlin. Was sind denn hier gerade die Regeln?
Ausgangssperre, wann, was hat offen, was hat nicht offen, was darf ich, was darf ich nicht,
gibt diese Information nicht. Da klickst du dich dann irgendwie auf Berlin DE und dann musst du irgendwie dreißig Links folgen, bis da irgend so ein behördenartigen Gesetzesgesetzvorlage oder Beschluss sehr verordnungsänderung vom so und zu vielen Hass nicht gesehen
In Paragraph drei ändert sich folgendes und dann hast du so grau in grau, Behördensprech, aber einfach mal so ein klare Ansage, das hat zu, das hat nicht zu
Das hat zu bleiben das nicht,
oder eben wie wir das hier auch schon besprochen haben, dieses irische äh oder ich glaube, Großbritannien, das ist ähnlich, dass wir halt einfach eine klare Ansage hast. Es gibt fünf Warnstufen.
Man befindet sich gerade in der und was.
In dieser Warnstufe gilt für die einzelnen Kategorien entnimmst du dieser Tabelle fertig. So und das das finde ich ist eigentlich mit fast das größte Versagen, dass wir so einfache Kommunikation nicht auf die Kette bekommen haben.
Am besten gleich mit Bußgeldkatalog auch.
Genau, Kost, genau.
So und Verstoß äh äh kostet. Ich meine, was wir dafür allerdings bräuchten, wäre halt ein Konzept, einen,
Plan äh so dieses sozusagen diesen abgestuften Maßnahmen im Katalog, der nicht so ad hoc alle paar Wochen äh,
umgeworfen wird äh und äh der komplett ziellos ist und ähm ja äh wo es keine klaren Grenzwerte gibt oder keine
klaren Mechanismen, wann, was passiert, dabei wäre genau so etwas auch der beste Weg
so politischen Druck stand zu halten, indem man halt einmal diesen Katalog aufstellt, dann eine Selbstbindung vereinbart und dann sagt, okay, so machen wir das jetzt, so wird das jetzt durchgezogen, ja? Und.
Ja aber das scheint bisher nicht funktioniert zu haben. Bisher wollte sich.
Dann äh offensichtlich ja.
Ein Teil der Politik nicht binden lassen und äh stattdessen ja kommen dann irgendwelche Adhoc Maßnahmen und ich sehe auch nicht äh.
Wie sich das ändern äh sollte. Und das ist halt großer Nachteil ja und wenn man könnte es allerdings trotzdem,
machen mit der Chorona Warnep, das wäre nicht unbedingt eine Voraussetzung. Wer halt dann nur entsprechend mehr Arbeit bräuchte man noch einen Redaktionsteam, was äh halt dann,
sich jeden Landkreis einzeln anguckt, was da gerade gilt und dass dann irgendwo einträgt.
Ja, alles leistbar, aber wird halt der, gerade derzeit nicht gemacht,
Gut, lass uns ein äh Ende finden. Die Sendung war jetzt schon sehr lang. Ähm jetzt versuchen wir mal wieder krampfhaft einen optimistischen Ausklang hinzubekommen. Also unsere Tipps.
Äh äh haltet euch von Weihnachten fern,
haltet die anderen auch alle von Weihnachten fern. Ja, ich weiß, es gibt alles Debatten so, ne, aber die Wahl ist halt irgendwie dieses Weihnachten oder alle anderen Weihnachten,
Ähm und setzt einfach auf die Zeit, wo es vorbei ist.
Also so ich habe das für mich irgendwie alles schon abgespeichert. So, also Januar, Februar, März findet nicht statt.
Ja, es gibt keinen Spaß, gibt kein kein kein kein Barbesuch, kein Theater, kein Kino, kein kein Spaß, es wird einfach der furchtbarste Winter, den man sich vorstellen kann, es dunkel ist kalt und,
Kein Spaß so und das richtige Leben kehrt leider so nicht zurück. Just eadit.
Ist so und jetzt denken wir über das, was danach kommt
nach so Impfungen finden statt, es geht voran, irgendwann wird's wieder besser werden. Jeder von euch wird irgendwann geimpft sein und wenn wir dann alle geimpft sind, dann ist Sommer und die Sonne scheint und die Vögelein zwitschern und alles wird gut.
Und so was ich halt angefangen habe einfach eine Liste zu machen von all den Dingen die ich gerne tun möchte, wenn's wieder möglich ist. Das äh.
Wie geil wird es dann? Wie geil wird es dann wieder sein? Also ja da freue ich mich eigentlich auch schon am meisten drauf, aber bis dahin äh übe ich einfach den Verzicht. So so eine Art Mönchtum, was man jetzt so.
Sich auferlegen sollte. Gut, meine lieben Non- und Münche.
Haben wir denn schon einen Plan eigentlich für nächste Woche? Blöde Frage.
Ein Plan.
Na ja, weil ähm nächste Woche, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ja, ist der erste Weihnachtsfeiertag, Freitag.
Ja, machen wir wieder Sendung, ja?
Ja, auf Weihnachten findet ja nicht statt, also von daher ist es ja eigentlich egal. Also ich habe nichts anderes vor. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir so ist so.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, hast recht. Also äh nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Wenn dieser Staat weiterhin Zahlen veröffentlicht, dann können wir sie auch noch diskutieren. Vielleicht machen wir es einfach ganz weihnachtlich.
Genau, dann gibt's auf jeden Fall eine Weihnachtsausgabe von oder eine eine Nicht-Weihnachtsausgabe, wie auch immer.
Gut, bis dahin lassen wir euch erstmal wieder in äh Frieden, noch schönes Wochenende und äh.
Ja, tschüss.